[Music]
B
d
[Music]
w
yeah
[Music]
e
oh
[Music]
mus
oh
[Music]
B
by
[Music]
a
o
[Music]
ah
oh
[Music]
he
you've seen the speed chest
Championship now it's time for the rest
of us to get a turn
with no Grand Masters allowed it's the
I'm not a GM speed Chess
Championship watch your favorite chess
personalities duke it out in chess.com
exciting speed chess
format there will be brilliancies ly
stacking another pop Bishop C3 and Rook
a one oh Rook a one there will be
blunders no no he fell for it 16 players
are fighting for a chance at the eight
player knockout see old rivalries this
is how long new
foes with a $115,000 prize pool who will
take home the crown this year and that
is the match the imcc starts right
[Music]
now welcome back everybody to the I am
not a GM speeds Championship I'm Robert
Hess alongside me my good friend
my favorite co- commenter D how does it
feel to hear that com from my mouth man
I I'm already at a loss for words and we
haven't even started the show look what
you've done Robert super excited another
great day if I am not a GM SEC action
this is a match that I know the chess
community at large is very much looking
forward to well we have two players
participating today who bring the hype
one of them he is well known for as
being a YouTube sensation that is Levy
Rosman his opponent today none other
than Greg shahadi the commissioner of
the proess league and the winner of this
match faces the winner of the match on
the other side of the semi-finals
Paulina shiala against Lawrence Trent
Dan we have four players who have earned
their spot in the semis they absolutely
have and their Journey has not been an
easy one neither Greg's Journey nor
Levy's Journey they had different types
of Journeys but both of them qualified
to face each other in a rematch from a
2021 match that captured the attention
of the chess community at
things have changed in the intermediate
two years but the Rivalry between these
two players and the hype of a levy
versus Greg match has not and Levy is
always hyped we know he could sacrifice
the rook and he just published the book
so Levy Rosman is a household name who's
doing big things somebody who may be
more behind the scenes is Greg shahadi
we know him very well da we've known
Greg for pretty much our entire chess
playing lives he is the commission of
the proess league before that the United
States Chess League he was the 1996 US
Junior Open winner he of course is the
brother of Jen Jihadi and I think very
importantly as it pertains to this
competition he's a three-time
semi-finalist in four appearances Greg's
a great Blitz player he's a very
experienced over theboard player
obviously he doesn't play too much
anymore but at his Peak he was close to
2500 F close to becoming a grandmas and
he hasn't lost a lot of strength as he's
shown time and time again when he plays
online he still got it he's still sharp
and all of the time that he spends in
the Chess World that really really helps
him stay sharp another case in point
Robert yeah he lost elen rubers but came
right back defeats arabid 4-0 and the
defeated rubers in the tiebreaker match
to make his way to the match with Levy
yeah that went down to Armageddon and it
showed his nerves he's also a well-known
poker player so does that help him with
chess remains to be seen that's a
question that maybe nobody can answer
but we know that when it comes down to
the wire he's able to pull through and
somebody who didn't need to go all the
way down to the very last match who
secured it by winning all three matches
in his group is Gotham chess Levy Rosman
instead of doing talking about others
chess he let his chess do the talking
and we obviously see the bullet points
we have to go through them as
commentators but if you don't know Larry
Rosman if you don't know that he's got
the YouTube's largest chess Channel
where have you been how big is the rock
that you have been living under Levy has
been electric the last couple of years
and he's also a fantastic Blitz player
recently defeated Ali Reza in a title
Tuesday so nothing to sneeze at on
YouTube and definitely nothing to sneeze
at over the board as well well there
might be something to sneeze at is it a
vacuum cleaner I see in the background
there could be dust but when the dust
settles Levy wide-eyed as he is right
now he showed that he can beat everybody
in his path it doesn't matter who he is
facing thus far in the imcc that is not
Greg chiadi that is Levy Rosman there
plus n differential beating Nemo beating
chess explained one of the most popular
authors on cheso and shus Royale the
youngster from England Levy was able to
get through all them and the way that he
won these matches could not be more
different he wins the first nine games
of the competition we thought that he
was going to go 40 against shes as well
suddenly he loses two games Levy's back
is against the wall he's losing the
decisive game and not only does he turn
that game around but he wins the next
one as well pulls the match out against
sh and avoids a tiebreaker Levy comes
through clutch in critical moments and
he needs more where that came from in
today's match which I think is going to
come right down to the wire he will need
more of that incredible form that he's
shown not just in the IMC he created a
video about it he beat Ali reaza in a
Blitz game in title Tuesday now we know
that a strong player can beat any other
strong player in a one-off Blitz game
but that does show a great deal of skill
he's in good form right now and he'll
need to be because if we rewind the
clock if we go back to the year
2021 we did see Greg shahadi take on
Levy Rosman and Greg had us in the first
half not going to lie you see he had 8
and 1/2 Levy had 5 and 1/2 after the
blitz portions but then look at the
bullet da 8 to two in Levy's favor he
showed who was in charge and how many
SEC matches have we seen this type of
narrative one player leads throughout
the match but you always have a chance
to come back in the bullet and in order
to win an SEC match against a strong
experienced player you need to stay on
top for the entirety of the match
including that last bullet portion and
that is Robert a big source of concern
for Greg can he keep up with levy on the
clock can he keep up with levy on the
mouse there's no question that Levy is
the more experien bullet player he's the
faster player in time scrambles I think
that one of the keys to the kingdom for
Greg is to build up maybe even a four or
fiveo lead going into the final
segment and we're talking about final
segments and everyone who just saw the
group stage where four players took part
and they all played each other in these
mini matches there's going to be more
chess tonight than there was in previous
days because Greg and Levy they won't be
switching opponents it's just these two
right now and will start with 75 minutes
of the longest time control 5 minutes
base time with 1 second added per move
then they get into the middle time
portion 50 minutes of 3 minute plus 1
second increment and last but certainly
not least especially for Levy 25 minutes
of 1 minute base time with 1 second
added per move and I'm circling that
right now da because those final 25
minutes that's what separated Greg and
Levy the last time around it most
certainly is and if you're looking at
this time control and you're wondering
wait this is kind of similar to another
type of SEC that I've I watched Pretty
recently yeah very similar format to the
regular sec- 15 minutes uh in the 5+ 1-
10 minutes in the 3+ 1 and then 5
minutes Less in the 1+ one but yeah
Robert 25 minutes still plenty of time
to completely turn the match on his head
so Greg will need to fire on all
cylinders for the entirety of these 2
and 1 half hours of amazing chess that
we are about to enjoy and no
distractions today because Greg can't be
thinking about Laurence shred I know
they're tweeting at one another but Greg
needs to focus on the matchup right in
front of him he is in the IMC
semi-finals for the third time out of
four total appearances who did he lose
to to not make it to the semis that was
Lawrence Trent so Greg he knows he will
have his hands full with Levy Rosman
he's somebody who can really handle
quite a hefty opponent he is a CrossFit
addict by his own admission you can see
him posting about that all the time on
social media but da right now when you
see that one verse one battle you look
at the FED rating that's in Greg's favor
but with both of them inactive over the
board I'm going to force you to make a
prediction whose way do you see this
match going I honestly think that it's a
lot of this is going to be decided in
the bullet just like it was in 2021 I'm
curious to see what Greg speed and yes
I'm deliberately stalling and trying to
make you forget what question you asked
me as I usually do but I think that
we're going to see pretty early on how
Greg is able to function under severe
time pressure what the time scrambles
look like I'm going to have to give Levy
the small Edge just because I haven't
seen Greg grinding those title Tuesdays
I haven't seen him practicing quite as
much in Levy of course he might not play
over the board anymore but he's he's
still Ultra experienced online he still
plays a great deal of bullet and that is
super important at the same time Greg
Savers these moments he loves these
moments he likes the big stage he likes
it when people are watching him and he
performs very well under pressure he
needs to harness that throughout the
entire match and he needs to make Levy
feel nervous if Greg wants to have a
serious shot well I love the way you
avoided answering the question directly
so let's give it to the chat chat what
do you think who is going to win today's
match will it be Greg shahadi the
veteran the commissioner of the proess
league or will Levy say good evening
commissioner and take him down because
Levy better known as Gotham chess to the
masses he has been locked in in recent
months he's ready to go and there is
quite a lot at stake because in addition
to making it to the finals there's prize
money up for grabs between these two
they will take home quite a nice nice
chunk of change and you see that
$2500 is given per match 1250 awarded to
the winner the other 1250 will be split
by win percentage so that is only
answered at the end of the match it's
not just the spot in the finals that
prize money is also up for grabs and we
all know da that at stake is pride is
Glory players want that I was about to
say the prize is nice but the pride uh
is the real prize and you can just see
it on Greg's expression he is just
savoring the start of this match you see
the thumbs up from Levy the players are
just about ready to begin this is going
to be all over Twitter everybody's going
to be watching this can Greg and Levy
lean into this moment and can they get
off to a good start big ingredient in
this match is going to be opening
preparation Levy Prides himself on his
opening preparation he's the author of
several opening courses but he's also
been pretty predictable in recent SEC
matches what will he bring to the table
opening wise and how has Greg prepared
against Levy's trow skis and his carons
and the other tricks that he has up his
sleeve there's only one way to find out
Robert it's a big question what
preparation have the players been doing
we know Greg he likes to do CrossFit he
likes to be in physical good physical
shape Levy's also posted videos recently
of himself boxing so both players taking
that element seriously but we do have
liftoff on the chessboard it doesn't
matter how packed your punch is right
now it matters how you deal with the
trumpi as you correctly predicted and an
early C5 by Greg already I wouldn't call
this an opening surprise C5 is less
common than Knight F6 to E4 and E7 E6 so
Greg trying to take the game out of
conventional territory early but it
appears that Levy has come prepared
immediately blitzing out Knight C3 and
the first think of the match is going to
be taken by Greg as he decides whether
to take on D4 and he
does and we saw a pre-move in response
that exactly what Levy was hoping for he
swings his Queen over to H4 so da we've
done enough commentary to know that this
has the makings of a kingside attack the
black king on E8 is in the center so you
may be saying what attack what king side
are you talking about but if you wanted
to push the E Pawn develop your dark
Square Bishop you might have to face
some serious questions on the king side
and it may appear that white is simply
handing over control of the center and
yes black can play D5 here but white
will Castle Queen's side and immediately
put pressure on the pawn I'll bet a
silver dollar that Levy is gonna Castle
King uh Queen side and he does and his
next move is likely to be E4 and the
position resembles a sicilian a lot more
than a trompowsky you would never guess
what opening this came from if you were
shown this position in
isolation and White's next few moves
seem quite obvious there's E4 so we do
now have Assist looking position next
comes F4 the Knight can jump out to F3
and that Queen on H4 is perfectly placed
now the one thing that you have to watch
out for with the queen and Bishop lined
up like this is if black can throw an H6
at at the right moment the good news for
black excuse me for white rather is that
H6 doesn't carry a threat because the
queen pins the H Pawn down to the loose
Rook on h8 so that's what all eyes are
on at the moment and Greg you can tell
he's unfamiliar with the Dynamics of
this position he doesn't know what he
should play and he actually castles in
to what I thought was going to be a big
attack and I think he's Banking and
pinning all of his hopes on the Move H6
now this move does carry a threat but
the catch is that white could still
ignore it white could simply continue
developing very instructive idea H6
Knight F3 and you could run into a
situation kind of akin to a fishing pole
trap where the Knight lands on G5 and
there's essentially no way for black to
prevent white from chasing the Knight
out of F6 and something excuse me
something tells me Robert that Levy is
still very much in his preparation you
don't play a move like Knight F3 in two
seconds if you're not familiar with it
and Knight of three received an X but I
don't agree with that assessment I think
that maybe on lower depths or without
all the work that Levy likely put into
this opening Knight F3 doesn't seem
quite as strong as Bishop takes H6 but
Bishop takes H6 was a forcing move
Knight F3 left more questions to Black
Knight H7 not the 100% correct response
from Greg but I actually like it da
maybe you don't agree but I think
trading everything off Bishop takes E7
Queen takes E7 back trying to offer a
queen trade even if you have strategic
holes in the dark squares on the queen
side namely the C7 and D6 squares I
think at least you're not getting
checkmated so you're feeling better
about your chances that's exactly right
Greg is in I don't want to get mated
mode and Knight H7 is a pretty good
practical attempt now Levy has a big
choice on his hands is he better in the
end game absolutely but I don't think
that he should abandon hopes of a
kingside attack he does trade on E7 he
goes very positional and E5 super
instructive move for newer players
clamping down on the D6 square and now
Greg is going to have to deal with this
horrible D7 Pawn that's pinning the
bishop to its initial Square Levy's next
move likely to be Knight E4 he can get
the bishop out and he already holds a
2minute plus lead on the clock and I
mean that night on H7 there's no
question that Greg's end game is
miserable here oh it's terrible and
there great maturity great situational
awareness from Levy he doesn't need to
go all in for the Checkmate let me just
control key squares the bishop on seat
as you mentioned can't get out the D
Pawn is backwards stuck in place so F6 a
good try don't always listen to Ben fold
normally F6 is a move that makes your
king side more vulnerable without Queens
on the board F6 is a good start but down
my question is what if white plays
Bishop B5 let's develop that final minor
piece go right after the eyesore on D7
and ftes C5 it can be met with f takes
but in some situations it can be met
with the jump with a knight jumping into
E5 and in situations where the D7 Pawn
is eliminated Black's entire position is
likely to collapse like a house of card
instead a more conservative move by Levy
G3 overprotecting the F4 Pawn clearly
preparing to meet F takes C5 with Knight
takes C5 which is on the board and if he
can force Greg to play D5 that creates a
lot more problems than it
solves o because this looks like a
French defense and this is an ideal
French for white that E6 Pawn cannot be
defended by another Pawn as you're
highlighting right now Bishop H3 Rook E1
that Knight can always move back from E5
to F3 into D4 or that knight from C3 can
wrap around Knight B5 Knight to C7 or
Knight back to D4 and the bishop on C8
can hardly move this is not a fun
position to have for Greg shahadi he is
going to one by one try to stop White's
immediate plans but I just don't see an
active idea for black probably rook d8
and then if I gave you a free move da
after Rook d8 what would your next move
be man that's that's a great question I
would try to find some way to sacrifice
a pawn in order to free up the position
I think Greg is preparing Knight C6 but
this is what you're saying Robert every
time you close a door 10 other doors
open now the Knight comes into C7 the
position is collapsing on all seams the
problem isn't just that you're losing a
pawn you might lose a lot more than a
pawn here I don't see a move for black
this is borderline
resign it looks completely losing
because you play Rook B8 or you move
your E8 Rook Knight C7 still Forks one
of the Rooks and the E6 Pawn you're
picking up material so I think the best
case scenario for Greg is losing a pawn
and hoping you have enough compensation
around it but it looks to me like you're
going to lose even more than a pawn at
this stage Black's position is
absolutely miserable yeah there are some
cases where you can give away a pawn and
solve some of the problems in your
position like get rid of a very strong
piece but here White's going to win E6
and he's going to maintain all of the
assets of his position moreover the E
file is going to open up and then Greg's
Knights are going to get caught in the
crosshairs now Levy could also sit on
the position a good you know Russian
school boy might consider a move even
like A4 or B3 because black is so
paralyzed that you're not actually in a
big hurry to play Knight C7 but I
personally Robert I wouldn't be able to
resist that juicy nectar of the Pawn on
E6 you earned it I think that you're
right you should go in and win it uh one
of the things that Levy has done in
addition to building up a great position
is building up a huge lead on the clock
so he has sufficient time to invest even
45 seconds a in it at the stage and then
try to come up with the best plan is it
Knight C7 grabbing the pawn right away
is there that move A4 or B3 or some kind
of move on the queen side just a slow
move but black does have a move like
Knight E4 at some moment not now because
Rook takes E4 wins a free piece but if
black is able to get active maybe that
would be the necessary counterplay to
give Greg a chance in the end game
Levy's taking a large chunk of time here
he's definitely deciding between Knight
C7 and a slower approach he could also
apply more pressure on Greg's D5 Pawn
with a move like C4 and he plays it C4
chipping away at the pawn chain Levy
keeps Knight C7 for a rainy day and he's
trying to enhance the power of the move
Knight C7 because now if the E6 Pawn
collapses with Tempo then likely the D5
Pawn is going to collapse right after it
but Greg can play Knight E8 here and
that stops Knight C7 and then after
black plays A6 and kicks the knight from
B5 then the Black Knight is the one that
goes to C7 and suddenly all of blacks
weak squares and weak pieces are
defended but he goes active D Knight to
F5 played and I think Bishop takes F5
followed by Knight C7 that Scoops up the
D5 Pawn Yeah it's always scary to
transform your advantage but this is
pretty cut and dry take on F5 throw a
knight C7 C takes D5 you get a huge pass
Pawn on D5 and the Knight on C7 is
completely safe not only well he takes
with the Knight on D5 I like that a
little bit less but with 20 seconds on
the clock I if Greg holds this that
would be a huge confidence boost to
start the match look at that Knight on
E5 look at that passer on D5 and Levy's
pieces just perfectly poised uh to push
that pawn All the Way Forward eventually
to
promotion every single move that Levy
has played has had a clear purpose it's
the clarity that I love to see from him
in this game Greg he's floundered a bit
trying to come up with defensive ideas
he has a hopeless Bishop against a
stallion on E5 that Knight completely
dominates in this end game and if Greg
survives us somehow it's going to be
because he wins the D Pawn he needs to
play Rook D6 rook d8 and maybe then
Bishop F7 give up his Bishop for the
Knight but the Knight could always jump
back to C4 kicking The Rook away that's
why the Rook is not as effective of a
blockader but you're right if you push
D6 too early and that's why you see Levy
bringing his Rook to E5 all handson deck
he's going to snap off another Pawn on
F5 that gives him a little bit of
insurance even if the worst case
scenario happens which Robert it's not
because I think he's just going to drop
his KN back to E3 get his Rook back to
the E file and continue slowly
accumulating his Advantage if I was
facing Carlson on the black side here I
would have resigned like 5 years ago
this is just this is hopeless oh it's
just a miserable position for black
white is currently up two pawns the D5
Pawn is defended by all three of White's
most valuable pieces and I love the move
G4 he's gaining even more space d after
H takes G5 check King G7 F5 you can't
even take the PA there F5 is a four
and Flor and the f paon is going to
reach F6 it's going to be defended by
Gary the gpon instead infiltration on
the seventh rank in such positions
there's always going to be five or six
ways to win Levy could also just bring
the king up into the center he is
playing a stellar a superb positional
game I can't point to a single
inaccuracy that he's made all game he
just needs a couple more careful moves
to finish it off don't go King D4
whatever you do don't blund the D- Pawn
cuz that's going to greatly complicate
the winning task I would play even Rook
D4
get the Knight to E5 easy clap and he
does all of that so the pwn F4 is under
attack he defends it with his Rook he's
bringing his Knight into E5 now D every
move has made perfect sense and with D7
I think available at this point with
Rook D6 to follow that's game over but
King B5 also a nice move this I always
love King infiltrations to end the game
this shows us how important King
activity is in the end game that King is
going to get to C7 the Knight is going
to slide into C6 and look at how all of
the pieces have fallen into plays
perfectly for Levy as he finishes the
game by promoting to a
rook oh the meme Master Levy Rosman
takes the first game in fantastic
positional style he added insult to
injury there by promoting to aook I say
it quietly because I know how loudly he
the but da in all seriousness that was
an unbelievable game from Levy like
truly that was fantastic from start to
finish that's a model game for those of
you at home I I know you already are big
fans of Levy but go look at that game on
rewind because he made it look easy even
though some of the decisions that he had
to go with were several moves deep I
have to give him credit where it's due
I'm going to repeat what I said in the
previous game Robert I read a stat that
Queen Cleopatra uh lived closer to the
invention of the iPod than the building
of the Pyramids of Giza well 5 plus one
I think is closer uh to classical chess
than it is to Bullet you can play a
classical level game in 5 plus one and
Levy just
did he really did and now he goes to his
trusty kakan he loves this opening uh he
is now up one nothing we see the score
on the side it will be fixed in a second
don't worry everybody but you see that
this position is one where white has a
pair of Bishops but the light Square
Bishop for white not doing so well
against the mass of Pawns from B7 to D5
so that Bishop will struggle to find a
useful diagonal in the future yeah very
quiet position let heavy definining the
pawn structure by driving his Pawn down
at D4 because the center is relatively
closed you often see white making a lot
of moves with the same piece and it's
not like White's King is unsafe uh or
the situation is volatile white can
often afford to C casually play D3 and
then redeploy the Knight to D2
eventually white might slide the queen
over to G3 in order to pave the way for
a kingside expansion I'm curious how
Levy is going to set up his Pawns in
pieces here you see him continuing to
Span in the center with E5 likely he
will play C5 and Knight C6 but as a
king's Indian player I tend to like the
wh side of these types of positions even
though it may appear cramped the fact
that you've got the bishop air and the
fact that you've got the eventual idea
of pushing F4 I think gives white a
pretty clearly defined
plan oh I'm with you completely and
white will try for F4 black usually
plays C5 and tries to expand on the
queen side now that Knight on B1 will
not stay there forever as you correctly
pointed out that Knight can go to D2 and
out to F3 and go after black center and
the reason why I also prefer White's
position is I see multiple Pawn breaks
there's C3 and there's F4 so I can break
both in the center on the D4 square and
on the E5 square and there's no Knight
H5 because the bishop on E2 stops any
sort of Knight H5 business so F4 is not
something that black can prevent without
question the bishop on G7 also kind of
lame of course it's keeping Black's King
secure uh but it's not actively
influencing the game as the Knight gets
out to D2 I think this position uh is a
lot more to Greg's taste than something
like they got in the previous game Levy
not trying to be unpredictable he played
a chowski in game one he played a caroan
in game two this is his main repertoire
and I'm really curious how his openings
are going to Faire against Greg and
whether we're going to see Levy changing
up those openings as the match goes
along so far game one was a success game
two I don't think Levy necessarily Minds
this position but definitely neither
does Greg as he gets the Knight to C4
applying pressure on E5 Robert and he's
likely to follow up with A2 A4 in order
to keep that Knight firmly entrenched
much as you do in a kings's Indian it's
really difficult for black to ever Kick
That Knight out you'd have to try for B5
but as you're correctly highlighting
that A4 will take that away the E5 Pawn
currently is hanging so it it is in fact
something that white can take and that's
why Levy oh he goes for B5 but after
Knight takes E5 you see Greg's face
there he's like are you sure you can get
away with it the engine says the blunder
9594 D takes E4 and D the B5 Pawn is
hanging at the end of the line and I'm
not going to put that on the board
because I think Greg shahade is going to
do us that service he doesn't really
have much of a choice and that's the
unfortunate thing about B5 Greg's not
going to drop back to A3 his pride won't
allow that so even if he's not sure what
goes on after Knight takes E5 Levy is
not giving you much of a choice Knight
takes C5 I mean Rook takes E5 might be
tempting Robert to a newer player but
not all discovered checks lead to Rome
after Queen takes E5 there is no good
way there's no good Square for this
Knight to jump to I think Lev is going
to end up dropping B5 and he is in big
trouble here and you see Greg does take
on E5 he built up a healthy lead on the
clock to start this game that allowed
him to spend 44 seconds to deliberate
whether or not to take so he takes on E5
black takes on e4 D takes E4 to my eyes
seems pretty forc I'm not really sure
what Greg's thinking about here but the
B5 Pawn is loose because the bishop on
E2 sees across the newly open diagonal
and to make matters worse after lary
recaptures on E5 white is going to meet
fire with fire the pawn is going to
advance to F4 the E Pawn is going to
push up to E5 and not only will white
build a big and intimidating Pawn wedge
in the center but there will be the
massive threat of deploying the bishop
to the long diagonal this is actually
what causes black well maybe L can
actually go A6 and create a LT score for
his Rook but the point is that White's
also positionally better White's got
this big Center White's got the bishop
air and once the Center opens up and the
queen side opens up which it will if
Greg plays A4 I think the light scri
Bishop is about to have its moment in
the
sun it will but that Knight is coming
out to C6 saving the rook in the corner
but I love your move A4 I think that's a
very very smart move and Greg Jihadi
agrees with you D let us develop that
Bishop if black plays C4 here that
doesn't actually carry the threat that
you think it does because D3 in some of
these positions can be met by Bishop to
E3 you check me I Counterattack your
queen that gets messy but ooh this Pawn
structure looks terrible for black so
Levy needs to be active right now yeah
look at the light Square weaknesses Levy
gave the gave up that light squar Bishop
a long time ago back when it seemed not
to matter but once this bishop gets to
C4 boy oh boy what you wouldn't give to
have its counterpart sitting somewhere
on E6 I would play Bishop C4 you could
also slowly accumulate your light Square
control with a move like B3 but I
wouldn't necessarily procrastinate I
would get down a business instead we see
that kind of slow play by Greg King H1
just getting the king out of the line of
fire of the queen this C4 D3 idea was
kind of a headache and he's setting
himself up for uh a trap free future and
Knight B4 which is the main active idea
for black it would always be met by Pawn
to C3 so it wasn't scary the Knight goes
back to E7 wants to wrap around to F5 to
kick the queen out or to D5 if you take
away the F5 Square but I think right
about now is when Greg can think not
just tactically not just for checkmate
but that lonely A7 Pawn is there I was
going to say queen A3 in his future with
a bishop E4 now instead of Bishop F3
which is what I was going to highlight
but he's just trying to kick the Rook
out of the corner and go after that
lonely a pawn another button that he can
press on demand is this move Rook A6
it's a tempting move you bring the Rook
up to the sixth rank laterally
pressuring G6 in some situations you
could push F5 but like you said Robert I
wouldn't try to play this tactically I
wouldn't try to force anything against
Black's King in this position F5 is
Unthinkable because you're going to give
up E5 and you're going to give black a
ton of activity you called it Bishop
comes out to E4 but Lev is going to
protect the Knight with his Rook he's
also going to centralize and I'm not
sure I love the fact that Greg has his
Bishop on e4 rather than on C4 I think
that Levy could try to seek a lot of
counterplay here with a timely Knight E3
jump maybe even in this very position I
love Knight E3 sacrificing material for
activity actually maybe you don't even
give up material because many of White's
pawns are loose you know what another
idea is G5 for black he chooses your
option but the whole point is that you
are trying to collapse White's defensive
setup and so Knight E3 says please take
my knight open up the defile for my Rook
the King on H1 it seems safe but not
when files and ranks are for the blacks
rad and the bishop on G7 has lay dormant
for so long just kind of biting on
granite I said the light squirt Bishop
was going to have its moment in the sun
it did its moment in the in the Sun is
up and if that Bishop gets to H6
suddenly the F4 Pawn is under Fire
suddenly White's heavy pieces are kind
of scattered about on the king side and
White's King is feeling all alone over
there in the
corner and there's a forcing line here
Bishop takes Knight Pawn takes Queen
takes sorry Rook takes trade on d8 for
first of course and then Queen takes E3
so many of the Pieces come off Greg says
I don't like the look of that my king
wasn't going to feel so safe lonely on
the first rank so Rook G1 intending to
meet Bishop H6 with G3 and here's a
blunder for you da if Bishop H6 G3 G5
there's Rook A6 and that Bishop on H6
will be loose oh what a what amazing
lateral awareness I love those lateral
side to side pins they're so easy to
miss Levy starts with G5 so he combines
our idea starting with Knight E3 and now
chipping away at White's Pawn chain Greg
could still meet this with
G3 I mean 48 seconds Greg finally
eliminates that headache of a knight on
E3 he takes twice on E3 but now Levy is
finally gonna break down this Pawn chain
with G takes F4 he's probably goingon to
recapture on E5 and he's looking better
than he has for most of the middle game
is Levy but what what he wouldn't do to
put a pawn back on G6 to help his King
feel a little safer so on one hand you
are challenging White's Pawn structure
in the center on the other hand that
Bishop on e4 is so much stronger on the
light squares because it has a direct
path towards the black king and G takes
A4 Queen takes A4 now the F7 Pawn would
have been vulnerable so Queen D4 is an
excellent choice from Levy he
desperately wants those Queens off the
board he is begging for a queen trade
especially because that Rook would have
landed on D4 skewering the bishop in the
fbon but Queen F3 what a nice collected
response by Greg and what a difficult
position to handle with 20 seconds
tactics Galore here Robert with Bishop
H7 and queen H5 the immediate Queen H5
is a devastating threat he moves his
Rook out of the way I didn't even notice
that it was hanging what a tricky move
by Levy and queen H5 there would have
ended the game o sorry but now but now
Queen F5 ends the game like leev went
Rook f8 defending the immediate threat
Queen Oh wrong way H6 now queen5 was
Checkmate it was literal Checkmate now
he threatens it but he's too late Levy
gets his Queen to E5 and Rook D4 he's
going to win the bishop the bishop is
pinned here Rook E1 if Rook E8 there
Bishop H7 check so there are tactics
that Levy will have to figure out after
Rook to E1 it's really a complicated
position at this stage F5 with Bishop D5
check and Levy is going to have to move
the king he has to move the king here
that's a difficult move though what a
move it would be king h8 the only way to
stay in this game and he finds it and
he's actually winning When the Smoke
Clears it's whites king that's likely to
be caught in a mating net if this Pawn
gets to G3 and right now it can go there
but Levy down to two seconds he needs a
move and he plays Rook check first and
that one
error oh
oh Ley can't believe it he was that
close to a crazy comeback you saw the
Grimace on Levy's face that really
pained him and for for Greg it did feel
like he had the upper hand throughout a
lot of that game but you tend to
remember the last mistake more than you
remember some of the earlier ones savel
caller the grandmas and famous
quipster he quipped that the person uh
who wins is the one who makes the a
penultimate mistake the second to last
mistake Greg had the last laugh there
now I noted that game down Robert
there's a detail in the end that I
wanted to show I'll do it after the
break right now we need to focus on the
next game because these players you know
what the SEC is all about you have
absolutely no time to recover you need
to move on you need to get away from
those negative emotions and start the
next game Levy has been really really
good at that thus far can he do it here
early in the match and I want to get
chat involved once again so many of you
predicted Levy would win the match it's
still early it's tied up but has your
opinion changed at all did more of you
believe in Greg please let us know who
you think will win this match between
Levy Rosman and Greg shahadi and done it
in this position it once again resembles
a sicilian white missing a d Pawn black
missing that Sicilian C pawn and I like
the way Greg is playing this game more
than the previous one where he first
walked into what looked like an attack
then had some huge holes in the position
now all of Black's pieces that have
developed not the bishop on f8 cuz
that's stuck at home the developed
pieces make sense and there is what
looks like the natural Rook C8 those
kind of attacking moves for black yeah I
mean I would start by kicking the can
down the road and getting The Rook to
see it Greg might be trying to find ways
uh to involve this bishop if you gave
him two moves in a row well okay other
than Queen takes A2 Queen takes B1 let's
be real here for a second I think he
would play G6 and Bishop G7 and if you
could get that Bishop to the long
diagonal all of Black's problems would
be solved obviously G6 could be met with
Bishop takes F6 and Castle's Queen side
that wasn't in my list top list of five
moves that is not a move that you see
often in the Sicilian in any variation
didn't I just say to put a piece on C8
but the Rook the King this is an
unbelievable Choice from Greg he decides
to Castle on the same flank that white
is castled to and I think his claim is
that well if I went to the king side I
might fall into an attack wait Bishop
takes A2 check blund by Levy deflection
that Knight is overloaded guarding the
bishop in the A2 Pawn these are the
kinds of small tactics that you have to
see if you want to win an SEC match of
any kind and I feel like Greg
understands that something's up and he
plays Bishop takes A2 check I'm looking
for Levy's reaction none just yet but
there is no way he did this on purpose
because you would take back on A2
immediately or respond Levy had a blind
spot he blundered a pawn and now Greg is
the side for choice
but it's not a fatal violation that's
the good thing right you lost the A2
pawn it doesn't even fully compromise
the safety of your king your safe King
safety is still intact because Greg
castled Queen side he's not really going
for an attack against Levy's King
anytime soon maybe in some situations
the Knight is going to jump to B4 but as
long as Levy's Knight remains on C3
Knight B4 does not carry a big threat I
think Greg instead needs to focus on
trying to get this bishop out of the
game cuz you can't play without your
kingside forever so what is going to do
like play H6 at some moment to challenge
the bishop but even there Bishop takes
F6 Black's Pawn structure is bad the
dark squid Bishop will never be
particularly good and the a pawn is not
valuable for the time being that's going
to hurt white later in the game Don
would you agree that that's an endgame
issue more so than the current position
absolutely you already have to think
about potential end games because
there's a lot of PE trades on the
horizon there is one of them Bishop
takes F6 actually played on his own
volition and he meets it with Rook to D5
hitting the queen laterally lovely
looking move that Queen is going to very
likely drop back to C7 and Levy could
even lift The Rook up to B5 he could be
the one operating on the queen side uh
in just a couple of moves here and that
Bishop on f8 still does not have a
useful diagonal to work with sometimes
black thinks about move F5 to play
Bishop G7 and so that the bishop stares
down the length of diagonal but after F5
Rook takes F5 your F7 Pawn is also going
to be vulnerable you don't have time the
jettison the pawn in that manner so I
like A6 no Knight B5 jumps for you but
da what is the plan not just for black
but also for white yeah because that
Rook on D5 it looks really pretty but
the knights are like wait a second
there's only one parking spot in the
city I want it and he moves The Rook
over to H5 I was going to propose this
move the Rook trampolining from one side
of the board to the other and most
importantly he's vacating the D5 Square
for the Knight but Knight D5 Robert it's
a one move threat what is going to be
your followup after black calmly drops
the queen back let's say to C8 maybe to
D7 how are you going to create actual
chances because as ugly as Black's Pawn
structure is all of the pawns are
actually pretty well defended it's hard
to get to any of these weaknesses in
particular I'm going to offer you a draw
Dan da something I almost called you
Daniel also something I don't normally
do because after Queen C8 Knight B6 you
can't play Queen E6 because I think your
queen gets trapped over there and after
Knight F4 Al the E4 Pawn was loose so
maybe I didn't even trap your queen but
I was thinking that I could just go
around and attack your queen over and
over and I was mistaken cuz E4 was loose
in that specific position man Robert has
offered me a draw I mean that that is an
honorable a lifetime I'm I'm truly at a
loss for words I don't think I'm I'm in
the right to turn it down so I'm going
to accept it but Levy is going to keep
playing and is he going to chase this
Knight out of E5 with
F4 is that Knight then going to jump to
C4 and is Greg going to try to create
some chances against Levy's King using
his Knight and queen well what's the
threat for black is Queen G4 the idea
here to trade Queen off because Queen G4
might still be possible even after F4 as
The Rook on H5 is loose God that's a
scary move to play here because that
Knight on G4 it's only evacuation square
is F2 but what a square that is because
once the Knight jumps to F2 it Forks The
Rook in the E4 Pawn great awareness by
Greg this forces the queen trade because
Levy has no way of moving his Queen away
and keeping both his Knight and his Rook
protected so we are going to get a very
interesting unbalanced endgame here and
there's one more bonus of having the
Knight on G4 not only does it threaten
Knight F2 with the E4 Pawn being loose
but it allows you to play E6 because
your knight on G4 protects the F6 pawn
and that allows the bishop on f8 to
develop at long last so uh black is a
pawn ahead I said it wouldn't matter
until the end game if Queens are coming
off the board we're heading towards a
queenless middle game an end game
whatever you want to call it black does
have the extra material Lev's taking his
time though which tells me he might be
taking the move Queen F2 seriously
noticing that Black's King is awfully
alone there especially with the Knight
surrounding it and that Queen
potentially diving into B6 Queen F2 had
to be taken seriously but ultimately he
decides on the queen trade now is he
going to try to surround the Knight with
Rook F1 the move E6 is incredibly
unpleasant not only because it kicks the
Knight away from D5 but also creates an
evacuation route for Black's Knight
through E3 and C4 let's also not forget
that black is up a here and the Knight
is going to seek its fortunes on F2 wow
Knight F2 he wants Rook D4 the only way
to defend both rook and E4 pawn and the
Knight is kind of Trapped down there but
with the Rook on D4 is E6 now available
Knight takes F6 Bishop G7 with a pin on
the
diagonal I think it is I mean Levy would
follow up with E5 but then the D5 would
open and that Knight on F2 could quickly
turn from a strength to a weakness great
tactical awareness by Greg shahadi here
and Greg he seems to be in the driver's
seat right now he's well up on the clock
as Levy approaches one minute remaining
and Greg remains a pawn ahead his Knight
is not going to get trapped how do you
even attack that Knight your rook's on
H5 out of play your Rook on D4 can't get
to it and he's allowing Bishop G7 which
Greg seems completely surprised by it
and maybe Greg missed E5 maybe he just
thought that Levy's position should fall
apart here but the piece of good news
for white is that if black plays D takes
E5 The Rook on D4 is protected by the
Knight on E2 so Levy could recapture
with the F Pawn and I think his position
as a result remains intact he's no
longer playing to trap the Knight on F2
he's just trying to keep his position
together and I think he's doing a pretty
good job of it after F takes E5 it looks
like it should be bad for white and he
throws in Knight D7 check because the E5
Pawn can be captured by the Knight and
Greg didn't see that one coming either
so Greg is not really fully aware of
some of White's opportunities but his
position according to the engine Still
Remains positive indeed King C7 I think
is likely Knight takes E5 the smoke is
finally starting to clear now the big
question will black eliminate that
Knight the bishop on G7 is a lovely
piece it's on the long diagonal but the
Knight on E5 is a major headache you
certainly don't want to give up F7 white
sort of threatens to take on d8 and take
on F7 in some situations you could even
throw away some of these queenside pawns
and go after the second rank but I think
Greg's going to choose a simpler
approach but he doesn't have the easiest
followup in this position because after
Rook d8 they move C3 looks pretty
stabilizing and this H6 Pawn is loose
and that keeps the bishop on G7 tied
down the F7 Pawn is now threatened so if
you play Bishop takes E5 F takes E5 H6
is loose and he's going for this
variation so I don't know what Greg sees
but I'm starting to get worried about
his position I am too if you could
reposition this Rook to the second rank
you would more than happily part ways
with your H6 pawn and generate
counterplay against White's King as long
as this Rook remains on black side of
the board Bo Greg is going to be worse
here this is a long-term weakness Knight
D3 indirectly protecting H6 and
counterattacking E5 that is an excellent
Move That Knight could also jump to F4
it could also jump to E1 with check and
we're going to get a really interesting
end game here this is far from a draw
Robert this is actually very unbalanced
it's anybody's game all three results
are possible right now and the engine
says oh it's zero no big deal and I'm
looking at this like wait white has an
outside pass Pawn on the king side black
has outside pass Pawn potential on the
queen side and the king is more active
for black so I would play King C2 here
for white get my king to the center I
just don't know what White's actual plan
is it seems like your pawns are bit
Frozen in place and he throws the pawns
forward in order to prevent King F6
obviously there are tactics down the
seventh rank that you have to watch for
Knight takes C6 in some situations if
the king loses contact with the E6 pawn
and we're going to get our first allout
time scramble of the game so let's keep
an eye as both of these players try to
navigate this complicated end game with
less than 20 seconds on their clock and
that Rook doesn't have a lot of squares
but H6 seems safe enough and the King
for black is once King of the Hill but
White's King in the center as well but
this C4 move is good because of Kick the
king back but da there's some potential
for black on the queen side white
doesn't have too many pieces over there
in case his pawns are threatened and
Greg trying to control as many dark
squares as possible keeping his King
stable in the center with 4 seconds Lev
attacks F7 and a check by Greg I feel
like Greg's position is getting
overextended though especially if this
Rook get to F6 and if the knights come
off the board and Greg's got no choice
he's got to go for the Knight trade and
he's now firmly worse that move Knight
E4 received a question mark but I think
it was a good idea because look at him
kicking back Black's pieces and oh
Knight F5 check is going to hurt uh oh
and now the hon is going to be sent
forward and Greg had one second he's
going to flag and he's losing H5 is
coming okay but Knight G7 check that's
an awkward move what's that Knight doing
on AG five I think Levy is all oh he
wins on time but da that was nervy play
from Levy you could tell that he had a
great position but then he was making
Knight G7 check Knight H5 moves that
didn't really have a clear sense of the
position definitely nervy play but
earlier in the end game he did outplay
Greg there was a point at which Levy had
5 Seconds Greg had 20 seconds White's
position was always easier to play but I
agree he needs to be more clear on what
his plan is in those time scramble
situations if he had sent the H Pawn
down the board his position was already
winning but sometimes Robert you're just
too mesmerized by your opponent's clock
you see it coming down to. 3 seconds on
every move and at that point you're just
trying to feed unexpected Moves In order
to get your opponent to flag ultimately
the strategy worked in that game it's
2-1 it did just just throw the pieces
somewhere and hope that your opponent's
clock ticks to zeros that's what
happened Levy currently leads 2 to one
this has been a quite a balanced match
thus far I know we're only three games
in so that's easy to say but I like the
way these two are competing they're
playing very strong chess they really
are it's high quality chess both of
these players have had good moments
they've had not so good moments for Greg
I don't think any systematic changes are
necessary he needs to continue playing
fast and so far the position that we've
gotten out of the opening has really
defined the course of the overall
game and we look at this position it has
kocon Vibes it's Levy's favorite and in
this position it's been an exchange Caro
where white is trying to look at that E5
square and black can play E5 at some
moment but that leaves you with an
isolated Queen Pawn the D5 Pawn becomes
a Lone Ranger and that is not very fun
for most players to work with Knight H6
by Levy this is a common idea in the
exchange Caro now sometimes the Knight
gets to F5 that's the conventional way
of playing but other times if you want
to play more ambitiously you see black
playing F6 I know Ben find gold cringing
somewhere the Knight drops back to F7
and you ultimately try to expand in the
center with F5 Levy goes for the former
former idea feels like white is a slight
advantage because of his control over
the E5 square and just the nicely
coordinated way that Greg has position
his pieces but obviously black is ultra
solid here with no obvious
weaknesses and you see Greg play Queen
E2 lining up the rook and Queen on the E
file no E5 possibilities for black and
If This Were bullet white would
potentially throw the move G4 at some
moment you know how tempted you get when
there are few seconds on the clock let
me just attack something but I don't
actually think it's a bad move because
the wants to go to D6 but then you have
Bishop F4 to pin the Knight there so the
more I think about it G4 might kick the
Knight back to H6 and that's a really
ugly Square for it it's a gutsy move and
of course it could backfire in some
situations if black could challenge that
pawn later with F7 F5 but that's much
easier said than done the the final
problem in White's position is the fact
that this bishop doesn't have any good
developing squares and great stuff by
Greg kudos for playing G4 it's not an
easy move to get yourself to play but if
you can bring this Bishop out to F4 then
you're firing on all cylinders and
Robert F5 it may look scary but it could
simply be met with G5 keeping the king
side closed and later on white could
actually send the H Pawn down the board
so white could potentially attack on the
king side too I'm with you there and the
E5 Square would then permanently be
whites for the taking so a move like
Rook a to E8 makes perfect sense to me
just to sh up the center uhoh Knight E3
tactical shot you can't play E6 cuz the
Knight is loose on D6 is there any way
to successfully defend that pawn on D5
gosh that Knight on D6 is so misplaced
you would rather have that Knight on A7
on B5 anywhere but where it is because
if you play Bishop E6 not only is
Black's position kind of stuck in mud
but Knight G5 is now a major possibility
I would just throw that move in and
maybe just chill on G5 I wouldn't even
rush to take on E6 because that might
help black produce some counterplay down
the f file you could also just make a
slow move like R1 when I say that black
is stuck in mud I really mean that it's
very hard for Levy to find a followup
move here it looks close to being lost I
see the eval bar saying it's much better
for white but not overly significant but
to my eyes if I were playing this in a
Blitz game from the black side I'd be
worried about Knight takes E6 the Knight
moves away from E3 my E6 pawn my doubled
E6 Pawn is in trouble but perhaps black
will play a move like Knight d8 after
the capture on E6 but D I'm looking at
this not only is Knight takes E6 a
threat as you mentioned you can leave
the Knight on G5 play H4 H5 try to open
up that Bishop on
D3 yeah Greg's opening play thus far
with the white pieces has been superb I
mean to get this kind of position 16
moves into a caroan Levy's pet opening
not easy to do and Levy has to muster up
his troops bring everything into the
center and try to keep his weaknesses
protected he plays Queen A5 not really
sure what he wants maybe trying to
protect D5 one more time and Greg could
also start expanding on the queen side
that's the great thing about this
position you can can play casually
because even if black drops the bishop
away from D7 that Queen could then be
chased away with B2 B4 Levy is just
tangled up and it's so difficult to
untangle here can I ask you if we wanted
to be very direct for Greg right now is
there something wrong with Knight takes
E6 Pawn tak6 Knight G2 just defend our
loose Bishop attack E6 I feel like the
only way to defend for black would to be
retreating but Queen F3 is Greg's choice
he's putting another attacker on D5 if
Le's idea was to move that light squore
Bishop not happening because D5 is loose
not bad combining prophylaxis with an
improving move the only downside of
Queen F3 is that now Knight takes C6 is
a little bit less appealing at least to
me because after F takes C6 you're
walking into a pin against the bishop So
eventually you could tuck the queen away
on G3 and maybe even bring it up to H4 I
actually think Greg's followup might be
Queen G3 in this position I like Queen
G3 a lot Queen H4 is a huge threat
threatening checkm and also likely
winning at least a Pawn on the king side
he goes for it Greg is playing a
marvelous game these two are trading off
thus far where Levy won game one Greg
was able to strike back in game two then
Levy had a nice end game in the third
game and here it's a nice aggressive
position for Greg shahadi so with just
under two minutes in the clock down yet
Knight E4 played this is a bit desperate
but isn't there Bishop oh there's not
Bishop takes E4 Pawn takes E4 Knight E6
F E6 Bishop C7 something like that do I
get away with it wow that's great sharp
calculation by you that Bishop driving
into C7 pinning sorry forking the queen
and the Rook you do not want to play
Bishop takes C4 and then Bishop C7
instead Greg just goes for the pawn and
I think that's a great approach Robert
because there's actually a second order
Fork essentially you're forking a fork
you're forking two different Forks
because after Bishop takes C4 you're
threatening D5 that's Fork number one
and you're threatening Bishop C7 that's
Fork number two and there's like a metap
fork because you're forking both of
those Forks I've said the word fork too
many times did you just call it a meta
Fork because that was your most
brilliant a meta for oh I didn't even do
that intentionally wow you know Don it's
been a while since we commentated
together I I got I have to give you that
long overdue credit that was a sweet one
but that Bishop C7 hitting Queen and
Rook that was good step one and if you
take on d8 black does have e takes D3
and at least there is some life there to
Black B3 look at Greg go he's just like
let me throw in this move to attack your
queen and now what's he going to do you
often see players when they talk about
good form they say I saw the board well
you're like well what does that even
mean of course they mean it
metaphorically they mean it to say that
they see all sides of the board you're
aware of what's going on on the Queen's
side in the center and you're able to
push the right buttons at the right time
B3 forcing the queen onto an even more
inferior square and I wouldn't deal with
the mess after Bishop takes d8 I would
just pick up the pawn on e4 especially
in light of the threat of D5 but Greg
trying to go fancy he's going after
Levy's Queen and he's saying that after
Bishop takes E4 the queen guards C3 and
he'll be threatening Rook B1 but I think
Bishop takes E4 right away was Stronger
because of the threat on d8 the fork
with Pawn to D5 and this Knight C2 Rook
B1 so he could have kept it all in his
tool bag his tool kit instead he goes
Knight C2 right away he's making it very
clear what he wants and after Queen B2
Bishop takes E4 I'm not sure there's a
way to stop Rook e to B1 trapping that
Queen the position is collapsing on all
sides here Levy's falling apart at the
seams he's also falling apart on the
clock he's got 50 seconds he's got to
find some way to sacrifice Bishop D5 is
actually an excellent move because if
white tunnel Visions Rook B1 and maybe
Rook B1 is the best move at least black
will be able to get some material for
the Queen the game goes on yeah you get
a bunch of material I think you get at
least two minor pieces is and Greg is
going forward with this strategy and the
good news for Levy is it's Blitz not
classical chess there might not be
enough remaining for Greg to figure it
out when he has a minute on the clock it
sort of reminds me of the game between
Fabiano Carana and Sam Shanklin the US
Championship where Fabiano found some
excellent tactics he won Sam's Queen but
the resulting position saw many tactics
available for Sam shanklin's defensive
resources look at this E5 for black da
You' played so many Blitz and bullet
games if you take on E5 and the Knight
captures on E5 a rook lands on G3 and a
knight on F3 suddenly we're talking
about this getting very messy plus 4 is
such a misleading evaluation because all
you need to do is one mistake and Greg
already giving away some Pawns in order
to keep Levy's pieace activity at Bay if
your Levy need to keep your minor pieces
active I would take with the Rook if
you're Greg your top goal is to exchange
a pair of Rooks if you can get the Rooks
off the board then the damage that the
minor pieces are able to inflict
decreases by several orders of magnitude
so my automatic move move here would be
Rook D1 I think Greg's going to take
this game but this has been great great
resilient defense by Levy and he's got
to keep the Rook on the board and he
does and the d8 square is protected by
his Knight Bishop C2 Bishop C2 winning
another Pawn though Bishop C2 does allow
Rook D7 and white is getting a ton of
activity so you need to be careful if
you're Levy and also on the clock 15
seconds for Levy he plays your idea
Bishop C2 and he's playing this very
passively very passively I think he's
afraid of blundering a fork he's afraid
allowing the pieces to get to to active
but in so doing he keeps giving away
pawns and suddenly Levy has two minor
pieces and two pawns for the queen he
still lost but the game is a lot closer
than it was a couple of moves ago the
one issue for black the Knight on C6
that needs to get active 5 Seconds now 6
seconds for Levy but he desperately
needs that Knight to get into into enemy
territory that's and now the pieces are
starting to get picked T yeah great
stuff by Greg Queen D6 was a
fork and now he just gets to mop up
because he's Trading off pieces and I
think Levy wants to play on because he
wants to use some of the match clock he
remembers that match from 2021 bullet
chess was his best friend no question
about it if Levy can get into the bullet
with a Time match he will be more than
happy so every second is golden these
seconds that you take in recovery mode
also allow you to to take a deep breath
to adjust for the next game and both
players with the white pieces have been
absolutely Unstoppable Robert your
phrase trading blows the perfect way to
describe how this match has gone so far
and you see how locked in Greg was he's
like wait what's going on why is the
next game not starting there is a mid
time control break for both of these
players and I think that allows them to
look at their openings from the black
side we have a 22 match right now all
knotted up and da I think a tide match
is very fair these two players have
looked every bit even th far I've
enjoyed the match so much really from
the very first moves that opening game
in the trompowsky and opening Salvo by
Levy great Greg not to be outdone great
positional control well done in time
pressure by both players they're feeling
a lot of nerves they're feeling the
pressure to step up and perform in front
of their fan base and both of them are
doing it so far let's take a moment take
our hats off great stuff by the players
this match promises to be a doozy and
you mentioned fan base so all of you
watching let us know your thoughts in
the chat do you think that Levy Rosman
will win or can greet shahadi not just
keep the pace but actually outpace Levy
down the stretch let us know we'll be
back we're going to take a break just
like the players and we return it's more
on the I am not GM speed CHS
[Music]
Championship October is here and so are
some familiar faces Martin learned chess
just to play with his kids and
occasionally the family dog a workaholic
Philip hopes chess will help him relax
before he works his fingers to the Bone
Laura the librarian loves to learn and
has recently developed a penchant for
spell chess an aspiring influencer and
self-proclaimed meme Queen Isa can be a
monster on the board when she puts her
mind to it Paul morphy's undying genius
lives on to this day through his
Immortal Opera game just your average
old boss
nothing else to see here play them all
on chess.com
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chess.com and chessable one to
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click log in scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
going to ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable homepage now
the puzzle connect feature can be found
under Tools and you click puzzle Connect
Now what that does after you type in
your username is it's going to pull
positions from the games you played on
chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the position where you may
have missed the best move and the more
you play on chess.com the more games it
will have to quiz you as long as your
account stays connected it's pretty
sweet and it's going to help you get
better learning from the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature a
chessable but if you go to chess.com
link you can get 30 days of pro for
free
[Music]
w
oh
[Music]
and we were
and Greg Shaha there he's always talking
he's always writing he's always moving
he's always playing he's always eating
he's always working out and right now
he's always laughing because the match
is tied 2 to2 against Lev husman Greg on
Twitter he called it the biggest match
in chess history it started 54 minutes
ago they've already played four games
and we've got 30 more minutes of 5 plus
one action coming right up both players
I think doing a good job of negotiating
the butterflies in their stomach and so
far they've both had good moments
they've both had not so good Moments
White has won all four games in this
match but Greg shahade I think the big
question marks were on him everybody
knows how good Levy is Levy the more
experienced online Blitz player Greg the
rustier of the two but I think he's
negotiated his requirements pretty well
so far okay so we're watching the I am
not a GMC this is Greg Shah against Levy
Rosman tomorrow we will have the second
of our semi-final matchups uh featuring
lawren Trent and Pina
shalva okay so the games are about to
get underway and we will get Robert back
on the show momentarily there we see
Levy and Greg getting ready for the
second half of the five plus one Levy
recently releasing uh his Opus Magnum a
book for chess beginners and Robert I'm
very excited for these next 30 minutes I
think they're really going to define the
course of the match if Levy can keep
this within Striking Distance going into
the bullet he has to be th thrilled I
don't know what Greg is doing there but
whatever it is it's worked out pretty
well so far who drinks water like that
that felt you know a little strange but
however he gets his nourishment Greg
shahadi he is feeling amped for this
match sorry everybody had some technical
difficulties there but I am back the
players they're back they're locked in
and da it's 2 to2 the chat before the
match started they spoke and said Levy
was going to win 92% of them do you
think the chat says the same thing now
damn girl
I don't know man I think we might have
some bandwagon fans it's like those
Golden State Warriors fans you know they
win a game and they sing the teams
praise as they lose a game and they're
the worst team in the world people feel
confident in Levy's abilities I don't
think he's done anything to disprove
that so far but don't sleep on Mr
chihade that guy can play some M chess
and we're off with another Sicilian
trompowsky yeah that's maybe what we're
going to have to call it and this
opening it did well for Levy the first
time the second time Greg he was able to
steal a pawn and then he had a very
interesting position with his Knight
Galloping around but in the end of that
game Levy was the one who came out on
top and I don't know what Greg just did
over there he spent some time and he's
said ah whatever I'm going to play D6
Bishop E6 and is he going to Castle
Queens said again that's the big
question I'm not a fan of this opening
Choice by Greg I don't really know why
he keeps repeating move to C5 now what
do we see in SEC matches most of the
time players prepare a certain set of
openings
sometimes they mentally choose their
responses to whatever their opponents
can throw at them Levy is a tropski
player that's along with one4 that's his
main opening but you have to be flexible
if a line isn't working out for you you
have to have the ability to say okay
maybe I didn't prepare it but let me
play 294 let me play 2 D5 and try to
change up the position I think this game
is going to determine whether Greg keeps
repeating this line or finally makes a
change in their next game but I think
that objectively White's position is
just a tad easier to play because of of
the state of Black's King side and I
think that Levy will not make the same
mistake twice he's not going to play
Bishop B5 and hang that A2 Pawn you see
him thinking right now will he play Pawn
to A3 first to allow for Bishop B5 no he
went Knight H3 and it does seem like
Greg is talking so who is he talking to
it it's not he's talking in like the
meta sense he's always talking you know
even when there's nobody to talk to he
is talking yeah it seems that way but he
needs to uh just play the game that's in
front of him maybe he's up yeah who is
he talking to I have no
idea I mean usually we don't see I mean
we sometimes see Hikaru talking during
SDC matches why is that because he's
streaming I know that twitch.tv/ shahadi
has millions of fans but I didn't know
that channel was live right now maybe
he's talking to himself have you thought
about that Robert I'm asking the team
that's working so hard behind the scenes
and they say that it does appear he's
talking to himself that's maybe he's
popping himself up telling himself Greg
you can do it you know find tactics
don't make any blunders but it really
feels like he's having a full-on
conversation back in you know 2015 2016
before I streamed on Twitch uh I used to
okay this is really dorky but I used to
sometimes play Blitz on chess.com and
pretend that I was like a big streamer
so I would start like commentating my
games or I would like roleplay that you
know Robert Hess is commentating my game
to tens of thousands of viewers to each
their own maybe it helps GRE to
verbalize his thoughts maybe that calms
him down
I don't think it's a conventional chess
blank device but you know Different
Strokes for different folks oh now
that's a good one there and looks like
Greg he is now locked in and he plays
move H6 which doesn't necessarily carry
the threat you'd wanted to because after
Pawn takes Bishop The Rook on h8 was
loose Levy want to no part of that he
backs that Bishop up and is there
actually a threat that Knight wants to
moves allows the bishop to attack the
queen but is that something that Greg
actually needs to be scared of I think
he does I mean Knight D5 does not
actually maybe not because of Queen A4
and he is scared of it he drops his
Queen back to C7 but now this D5 square
is going to be claimed by White's Knight
this has made the move Knight F4
possible which is a move that Greg tried
to prevent with H6 he's relying on G5
but great tactical awareness by Levy
Knight takes C6 now comes with a threat
against Black's Queen making this move
this big positional move possible and
now D5 belongs to White here's a
question for you I know after G5 you're
going to play Knight takes E6 can I take
your queen on H4 we get into this
queenless position with the semi-open G
file white has a bishop pair how bad is
that for
black um somewhere between like bad and
miserable maybe actually not that bad
because the pawn on H4 looks like a
weakness but it actually kind of holds
down some of White's Kings kingside
pawns Greg doesn't want anything to do
with it though he drops his Queen back
to C8 and Black's Queen has been a
problem in this line overall Robert
first it's on A5 it's been a problem in
all of the games at some point it drops
back to C7 but he's just burning too
many Tempe trying to find accommodations
for this Primadonna of a queen on C8 and
that Queen is just doing a defensive
task at the moment although Knight E5
comes to mind as Black's next move
trying to hop that Knight into C4 and
there are some loose squares in Black's
Camp so Levy he just solidifies the
center with Pawn to f3s Queen now can
slide back from H4 maybe to E1 if that's
what the position calls for F2 being the
more likely Square I actually would do
that I'd play Bishop E3 Queen F2 and
line up my pieces against the black I
was say King side but it's the queen
side yeah great call it's the side of
the board that has the King which is
also the queen side not confusing at all
which is why on some broadcasts I think
uh the commentators refer to it as the
left side and the right side of the
board not bad but G5 Greg playing on the
right side of the board trying to
establish this Knight on E5 but but I'm
just worried about the long-term health
of his King if he plays A6 he gives up
the B6 square and slowly storm clouds
are starting to gather around the king
Levy could bring his Bishop out to B5
already he's creating threats against
the A7 pawn and if you can induce the
move A6 then these longterm dark squore
weaknesses are going to cost black in
the in the long run it does not look
Pleasant to make that move but Bishop
takes C6 was a threat so it goes Queen
C7 I like that a lot if Bishop takes
Knight Pawn takes back on C6 and A7
suddenly is protected I think this is a
great decision from GRE and I know I've
been frustrated by positions like this
when I feel like I should be better I
should be winning but I actually can't
find The Knockout and Black's next move
is Bishop G7 maybe Knight F6 back to D7
to follow and I don't see how white ends
the game and I see how black on the
other hand improves it would be nice if
you could somehow deflect this Knight
because Bishop takes A7 would not only
win a pawn you would also be able to
drop the bishop back to B6 so there was
this very interesting tactical move E5
trying to get black to Triple his pawns
along the E file instead Levy chiseling
away at black center dropping the bishop
back to C4 and vacating the B5 Square
for the Knight so I think his idea in
response to Queen C8 we're about to find
out but I really like the look of Knight
B5 again all of my play is centered
around one thing I want to force black
to play A6 so that you get this massive
Outpost for the bishop right in Black's
Grill this bishop B5 Bishop C4 grabbing
that back on the yo-yo string that was
really nice from Levy because he gained
a clear Tempo the bishop was back on F1
now it's out in C4 Knight B5 still a
great idea as you're indicating to go
after the weakened dark squares on the
queen side near Black's King so Knight
B5 looks great I'm looking The Clocks by
the way da it's about even on time do
you think that helps Black's defensive
chances or actually helps Levy in his
attacking possibilities in the queen
side it's a good question I think this
is where Levy's bullet experience really
comes in and we see Levy wreking on the
other side of the board good whole board
awareness by both players thus far in
this match also a big shout out we have
Jen shahadi uh completely unrelated to
Greg Shad it just happens to be a
coincidence that they have the same last
name and that she's in the chat during
his match why would anybody think
they're related just kidding big shout
out to Jennifer uh Greg's amazing and
very accomplished sister cheering on her
brother or I mean I don't want to make
any assumptions of
course of course we know Jen very well
here shout out to you and shout out to
that move E5 by the way I know we're
just talking about Greg and his family
but E5 is a move that could be a crush
yeah let's talk about the move I mean
that's a nasty move if you take on E5
you these triple isolated Pawns in the
center sorry oh that would I made that
move yeah but de Rook takes d8 you have
to take with the Queen the next Rook
slides over so Greg he doesn't mind
tucking his tail between his legs was
Knight to E8 his next move could be
Bishop G7 it's not the end of the world
even though it looks looks very
unpleasant for black B Kahuna Burger I
mean I think you called it Robert the
frustrating thing about these positions
you feel like you keep accumulating the
advantage but The Knockout blow keeps
eluding you and he still hasn't managed
to provoke A6 I'm I have a vested
interest uh in taking over under bets on
whether that move is finally going to
appear on the board I think if it is now
is the likeliest time because that old
threat if Bishop takes C6 and Bishop A7
is still very much the threat Rook takes
H4 Rook C4 and let continues to
accumulate the forces on the queen side
I was about to say King side but I
remember gets the queen side it's
confusing me as well and now Bishop
takes C4 you have to take with the pawn
Rook B4 check and after King A8 Bishop
takes A7 or Rook A4 it doesn't matter
these moves are going to really really
hurt so I feel like uh right now Greg is
about to get checkmated on that side of
the board and it's because he was not
able to fully develop his pieces God the
way that Levy has connected the king
side and the queen side is really
beautiful it produces an aesthetic
effect he played H4 five moves ago it
seemed to be completely unrelated to
what's going on on the other side of the
board Robert it's like those movies I
really like that have three inter
interconnecting story lines and you
don't see how they're connected until
the very last minutes of the movie well
we're about to see how the two sides of
the board are connected when Levy
shuttles and trampolines his Rook from
the h file preferably to the C file
although you can't do that quite yet
well you can play Queen E2 to get that
Rook over to C4 and if Black's best move
is D5 at any point your knight on E8 is
useless the bishop on G7 isn't helping
so he tries to develop that Knight right
away and there is tension in the center
I can see this oh what was that he BL he
allowed Queen Tak C3 and queen takes C5
and Greg could have been built a big
battery on the long diagonal but 10
seconds for Ley D5 makes sense as well
and black is not checkmated yet the game
keeps going what's the material white is
wait is white no white is up a pawn I
thought for a second white was Pawn but
where to next that's the big question
it's the a pawn so it doesn't allow
white to end the game at least not too
quickly feels like Levy has gotten a
little bit nervous in time scrambles
thus far in the match he plays Knight A4
but he yields the B5 Square to Black's
KNN and Greg has to get active at all
cost 5 seconds for Levy and D4 black is
developing counterplay active at all
cost the 9 A4 is useless over there he
play B4 but there has to be a problem in
White's position Rook D5 another
excellent by Greg and now White Center
is starting to collapse and the game has
turned
completely and if that black knight can
wrap around Knight D6 to C4 any moment
it's going to spell disaster for Levy
Knight D6 is a must you need to get this
Knight off of E4 Levy trying to hunker
down on the king side now the pawn
structure improving for black and the
queen is diving into C4 Levy trying to
break apart black center but he's just
giving away more pawns and just plant a
bishop on E5 at some moment that's going
to hurt and as we see a queen trade D3
is happening oh Bishop D2
but Rook C1 Rook C2 made wow Rook C2 and
he's just going to trade and promote
that is nasty vision from Greg and he
did all of that with 17 seconds on his
clock why did he give up that pawn what
is he
doing it's still winning but it needs to
be careful now if that D6 Pawn were
captured we would be talking about a
draw but that was smart of Greg to slow
it down right there his Rook does stop
White's G pawn and now it's clear that
the white king is pushed back the black
king infiltrates and it's Pawn pushing
time for black that was either a mouslip
or a bad pre but allwell that ends well
for Greg look at how the B Pawn holds
White's Pawn majority down that's it
Rook G1 you could get the bishop off the
diagonal and take the G5 Pawn anything
is winning what a comeback Victory what
a frustrating defeat for Levy who played
a brilliant positional game up until the
time scramble and this is looking like
our first victory for a player with the
black pieces of the match it was 2-2
both players trading off victories and
now the Deep Pawn is going to decide
this game and you don't want to give it
away that's all you want to avoid Rook
F5 Rook takes B5 is the easiest and the
rest don't go King
C3 but you know wait it's actually not
that easy you know what he's doing
though what he really wants to do is
waste time he may actually come close to
holding this game as you're indicating
but I really think he's just trying to
burn clock Levy wants the bullet no but
but how do you win this I think to win
this you need to go D2 why didn't he go
D2 he's had a million chances to do it
like right there D2 now now it's a
little bit less clear I feel like he's
trying to find the worst moment to play
D2 and you got to be a little bit
careful about repetition finally he
plays it and okay there we go and he
gets the job done it wasn't the cleanest
path to Victory but a victory
nonetheless so Greg chiadi is in the
lead for the first time in this this
match he leads 3 to2 so chat I keep
asking for your opinions you've been
telling us that you think Levy is the
favorite tell us now that Greg has the
lead are you changing your mind what do
you think of this match please get
involved but Don we're back to a kocan
the two kns position Bishop G4 taking
that Knight F3 is what we saw in an
earlier game and Levy he goes back to
what he played in the earlier game but
we did like how Greg was able to exit
the opening yeah and maybe this time
we're going to see Levy refrain from the
move for no he waits for me to say that
and then plays it that at that precise
moment I'm just not a huge fan of this
Pawn structure I think the bishop pair
combined with this idea of sliding the
queen over to G3 when the bishop on E2
is so nicely placed to restrict the
mobility of the Knight just gives white
an easier practical
game I like this yeah it's such a simple
plan for White Knight D2 Knight C4 Queen
G3 exactly what we saw Greg do in the
earlier game and Levy who felt
uncomfortable pushed that B Pawn you
remember that he decided to push his
Pawn on and try to kick Greg's pieces
back but it was too soon it caused him
some problems and Levy he develops his
Queen side first this time around so now
Knight C4 can successfully be met by
Pawn to B5 and Knight to B4 might look
scary but it can be successfully met
with C3 uh which is a move that you've
highlighted before also the E5 Pawn
would be hanging with Czech and a
different approach taken by Levy here he
delays Castle's King sence Ste he pushes
H5 and I think it's not so much that
he's trying to attack White's King as he
is trying to restrict uh the activity of
White's King side overall but Robert if
black is not careful this move might
actually have the opposite effect
because he is giving white a nice
parking spot on G5 for the bishop the
queen could potentially even drop back
to H2 and it does to maintain the
pressure on the E5 Pawn so black should
play Knight D7 oh that allows Knight D6
check I was about to say he should play
Knight D7 maybe KN D6 wasn't the end of
the world but my whole point was that
Bishop G5 was going to feel
uncomfortable especially with Rook F1 F4
to follow it's just a bit nasty for
black to deal with and the committal
thing about getting your Pawn to H4 is
that you're not really castling kingside
if White's Bishop sits on G5 because
then you're just going to drop H4 you're
also probably not castling queenside
although after what Greg did a couple of
games ago I think I got to be careful
about saying that but here I think it's
safe to say that castle and queens side
is instant Hariri well maybe Knight H5
which was not available in the earlier
game now that you pushed your Pawn all
the way up to H4 does that stop F4 from
White so I would be looking in that
direction and white with a pair of
Bishops wants to play on both sides of
the board so after Knight H5 I might
then play A4 and have you figure out
what you're going to do with your king
yeah White's under no obligation to rush
the move F4 positionally speaking
White's position is fundamentally sound
you could also rely on the other Pawn
break particularly if black keeps his
King in the center you could try to play
C3 and then you can kind of nibble
around the edges of the well time B2 B4
so I like White's position but I think
Levy so far is doing a pretty decent job
of preventing the situation from
spiraling out of control with F4 and we
see A4 played and there here's the big
moment will Levy Castle Queens side if
his King goes over to C8 I think white
knows what he needs to do start pushing
in front of the king and
G5 wow that's a big Choice yeah that's
like a moroi bind shifted three files to
the right
and it makes sense he is trying to
prevent F2 F4 at all costs and what Levy
is saying is yeah these moves might look
awkward and they might look weakening
but as long as you're not playing F4
where is your activity going to come
from that Queen on H2 is feeling awfully
lonely without the support of the bishop
and The Rook it's a very good point the
queen on H2 is a bad piece and how do
you progress from here I would be
playing on the queen side trying to play
C3 at the right moment he plays Bishop
G4 stopping black from castling so
that's a very good decision as it means
that the black king will have a more
difficult time finding true shelter God
that Queen on H2 is like when you're
driving through a mountainous area and
you see those houses on top of the
mountain and you start to wonder how
does a car possibly get to that spot
like how can you get to a space so
isolated how did that Queen even get to
H2 I don't even remember anymore I think
it did it through G3 oh Queen D1 F3 G3
and H2 it kind of fell uh into that
little envelope there and it looks
pretty but the pressure on E5 is
completely manageable black is doing a
great job of keeping this Pawn nicely
protected and here comes Levy striking
at the other side of the board and it's
time to retreat Knight A3 here defending
the C2 Pawn you can't push C3 as you're
point at Bishop D1 is also a reasonable
choice but I'd play Knight A3 and then
play Bishop D2 and just try to slowly
finish my development connect my Rooks
that Queen on H2 is ugly I give that to
you I don't like the location that it's
currently on but I do think that at
later Point D there could be a G3 push
to open up that flank and give the king
more Queen excuse me more squares as
scary as it is G3 might have been a move
that Greg wanted to play earlier now the
Knight gets to F4 and if you take that
Knight black will likely take with the G
Pawn then the queen on H2 will go from
bad to worse it might you literally
would be playing down a queen so Greg is
dealing with a lot here but his position
remains fundamentally sound and one of
the issues Robert with that move G5
which we largely praised is that there
are these light Square weaknesses so
black really can't open up the center F5
is a very difficult Pawn push to
engineer and as long as the center
remains closed white actually can afford
to play with a really really bad Queen
on H2 I like King H1 not because it
actually threatens G3 or anything of
that sort you're not going to open up
the H file because it causes Levy to
think and find a plan there isn't an
obvious plan for black heck there isn't
an obvious plan for white but you're
just passing the ton saying here you go
Levy your turn now and Levy at some
point will need to decide what's going
on with his King is it going to Castle
Queen he just said yes but that gives
white a Target now we know exactly where
the king will remain you should go after
it Bishop G4 check would be a good place
to start really expanding on White's
Monopoly over the light squares you
could then Shuffle the F1 or Rook over
to B1 and these types of positions are
about posturing as well as about actual
plans Rook fb1 is an intimidating move
you want to continue milking time off of
Black's clock so largely white is
playing without risk here white is the
one who's essentially calling the shots
and deciding whether to open up the
position or not black basically has to
sit around and wait and react to
whatever GRE does and this bishop on G7
a very bad piece the bishop on G4 is
better the bishop on D2 can't take at
the right moment on F4 and then you
follow with Pawn to F3 for White and the
queen will slink back G1 F2 and move on
over to the queen Queen side so I would
start by playing F3 there's no rush on
capturing that Knight and he does just
that oh
maybe yeah maybe he can go
in there was a crazy oh 92 N3 he walks
right into it now let me qualify this by
saying that I don't think exchange loss
is the end of the world because the
center is so closed I actually don't
think that white is all that much worse
here even though clearly Greg lunder
this move yeah and somehow the engine
didn't like Knight takes a rook which
means F5 which Levy wasn't even looking
at was available so I'm not even going
to bother showing that but there was a
tactic there that neither player was
looking out for and I have to say d it's
a closed position all eight pawns are on
the board for each side the Rooks don't
have open files I'd rather have the
minor pieces for some reason when you
said it's a closed position and then you
said the words all eight I thought you
would say all eight results are possible
for some reason that made sense to me
and look at this he blunders The
Exchange back it was the knight's moment
in the sun with a rook now it's the Bish
Bishop's moment to trap The Rook on E8
and then you could take take and go
Knight
B6 Knight B6 is sick cuz the Knight on
G8 is loose just don't play Knight takes
E5 as the queen will take with check to
the King on
H2 yeah and then F4 Queen E6 save the
Knight A6 first because after B6 then
Knight takes B6 oh you provoke the pawn
forward so that you can take it with a
discovered attack against the Knight
which is suddenly on its initial square
and x-rayed by the queen
I'll show this really really quickly
Robert as we wait for Greg to make his
move A6 if B5 then there are too many
weaknesses on the queen side Knight A5
and queen D5 is devastating and what
you're saying Robert is that B6 now runs
into Knight takes B6 beautiful hboard
awareness and then the queen is going to
drop back to F7 with devastating threats
against black king Greg misses it and
instead he dropped his Knight back to A3
maintaining a big Advantage but this
gives Levy a new lease on life and I
think he is going to try A6 to carve out
those light squares and at B6 we see
that white is going to have some fun but
there's no clear infiltration from there
it's aesthetically pleasing we have nice
control but we don't have a Checkmate on
the horizon but look at the clock that's
what I'm worried about right now Levy at
41 seconds Greg at over a minute it does
feel like it's easier to play for white
because his King is much safer there's
going to be one more game after this one
these are two critical games Greg shahad
is currently up a point if he can take
these next two games he will open up a
big lead going to the three plus one
it'll be a major confidence boost if he
could win a long positional Affair like
this one his Queen mining for gold but
operating on its own Robert that Queen
not only is not scary but Greg has just
gotten himself into a forced Queen trade
which is only in Black's favor in this
closed position of course black wanted
that Queen trade white does control some
Pawn breaks namely G3 on the king side
but with Rook still on the board I
wouldn't advise that just yet but wait a
second now I'm starting to think about
it more and more because after G3 a swap
on G3 the white King enters via G4 but I
want the Rooks off before I go for that
too passive by grg he gets his King to
F2 I think he's underestimated how dire
the situation suddenly is ironically on
the side of the board that he was
supposed to attack on now it's Levy
making strides Rook a I like that move I
really like Knight C4 and I like your
response Rook A8 don't open the B file
for that white Rook we are seeing some
trades but this isn't that easy as black
will play B5 and C4
and white needs to smoke this Rook out
of A2 at all cost but he might not be in
time King C1 C4 and you're not able to
play Rook B2 because of Bishop A3 but
King to D7 by Levy going for the other
side of the board and maintaining the
tension but King B1 and Rook A2 I think
Greg should be able to hold the draw
here yeah now if the Rooks come off the
board it's a clear draw I think Levy
would be advised to take that draw you
can't move your Rook off the a file as
in white is the one having all the fun
and Levy down to 5 Seconds he's thinking
about what to do and he brings his King
up allowing The Rook trade it's tempting
for white to keep pieces on the board
because black has five seconds but with
a one second increment no need for Greg
to be cute just make the draw keep that
one-point lead a result for white but a
good defensive effort by Greg in the end
game he didn't lose his mind uh he did
what the position required of him once
he blundered into the queen trade and
Levy pushing a pawn if it's captured the
king takes back and then there are no
more Pawn pushes available to either
player so yes white can play three well
not anymore there there's not much
happening in this position they're going
to shuffle around and for Levy this is
likely the penultimate game of the 5
plus one we saw in 2021 he was trailing
after the 5-1 he was trailing after the
3-1 as well and we see the game conclude
as a draw so he knows that even if he's
down a few games heading into bullet he
still has a chance he is not unhappy
with his current situation absolutely
not man if hikaro was on the black side
of that game I think he would probably
find a way to milk three and a half
minutes off the clock uh in that end
game but I think that neither player
mins an extra game to close off the 5
plus one segment it's been very high
level chess for the entirety of this
match so far and Greg repeating the same
line
again he likes it there's something
about this variation that he feels
favors him and Levy for a third time
changes his move in this position
there's Bishop B5 blunder there was
Knight H3 and now there's Knight to E2
and I don't know the big difference
between Knight H3 and kn2 besides the
centralization uh for that white knight
but Levy likes this
setup and there's an interesting
psychological component maybe I'm
reading a little bit too much into this
but I can speak from personal experience
I haven't played a lot of these matches
but one really annoying thing is when
you feel like you're always better and
you're always better out of the same
opening you always find a way to screw
up that starts affecting you
psychologically and maybe Greg isn't
such a big fan of his position
objectively but knowing that he won the
previous game and that he turned it
around I think he's putting a lot of
pressure on Levy to to prove that he can
win a game in this line and that can
seriously start tilting you're like why
can't I get a game in this line I'm
supposed to be
better it's frustrating yeah it really
is you're like bashing your head against
the proverbial wall and queen H5 so Greg
says you're not going to go for a
Checkmate against my lonely King this
time around even though Greg was able to
win the last time he had black but this
position is one where Greg says let's
get these queens of the bo Queen G6
would be tempting do
you yeah I was going to ask you you
already answered Lev is not going to
allow a queen trade no sir and I think
Queen G6 okay now I got to get get out
of that southern accent might be met
with a move F3 and you see this
sometimes in the ton of Sicilian if
white can trade Queens on his own terms
and open up the H file and set his
kingside Pawns in motion then we can
negotiate so I really like F3 I like
Knight F4 and I like the Prospect of
opening up the H file no question that
all of Black's problems are not solved
in the end game just because you're not
going to get checkmated doesn't mean
that your position still isn't super
cramped and poorly developed it is and
this is a great exhibition of that
Knight F4 forcing the Queens off the
board taking with the H Pawn the bishop
on E6 is under attack I don't think you
want to allow Knight takes E6 there will
be problems with defending that pawn and
so Bishop D7 a retreating move a good
one and da your plan is obvious F3 G4 I
like that but also we know about the
Sicilian even though there going to be
some tactical possibilities for white
with Queens on the board once Queens get
traded the foundation of Black's
position is often quite stable and
strong it is and a big decision now has
to be made by Greg where is he going to
deploy this bishop he plays this shenon
style with E6 now it's important to
point out that G4 H6 is ineffective
because G5 is possible anyway black is
lacking one tempo if you had Bishop B7
already in then you would be able to
play a H6 and keep this Knight on the F6
Square Levy could even in some cases
push this Pawn all the way up to G6
again because this Rook is constantly
going to be
undefended that looks great with G5 the
Knight has to go to E8 or G8 and then G6
because the Rook is not protected that
looks problematic for Greg very
problematic because if you can if you
have to play ftes G6 you're actually
just losing a pawn after Knight takes G6
and he missed the opportunity should I
show that really quickly
feel like that ship has sailed instead
G5 the Knight has to go back to the E
ranking the connection between the two
Rooks now G6 lovely idea shattering
Black's Pawn structure and the point is
that F takes G6 runs into Knight takes
G6 can't take the Knight have to drop
the pawn and have to give away the
bishop pair this would have been likely
a Calamity for Greg
Shah and it looks like in the game
continuation black was able to throw
throw those queenside pawns up the board
to chase the bishop around but there
must be a tactic here I mean G5 still is
available with G6 to follow and if you
don't want to give up your light score
Bishop you play Bishop A2 but then
you're looking at Knight C4 so G5 once
again that's going to result in a nice
position for white because you shatter
Black's Pawn structure it's one of those
things if Levy finds the idea he's much
better if he doesn't then Greg's
position remains fundamentally sound if
black can play H6 in some situations I
would even prer black like once you get
Knight C4 and you could actually set
your own queenside Pawns in motion Levy
still kicking the can down the road and
he's got another chance to play G5 and
G6 of course first I would choose to
eliminate this Knight Bishop C1 Robert
runs into the very important Knight
takes a three tactic that's a lovely
find by you and it's something that you
need to know if you play in a sicilian
quite regularly so Knight takes A3 would
be available the bishop moves G5 he
didn't spot it the first couple times
will he spot it now he's shown that he
doesn't want to give up the bishop for
that Knight but now is the time and wait
he walked into the tactic that you
mentioned but Dan there could be G5 G6
at the end of that if you do play Knight
takes
A3 and oh wow yeah there was Bishop B2
and G5 and H6 finally that ship has
sailed or has it because after Bishop
takes C4 again there's always this
problem of black losing the connection
between his Rooks and that allows white
to play G5 I would most certainly take
with a pawn there and he's allowed it
again he's allowed it again is it as
effective as in the previous times
Robert it looks good for White and the
Knight has to move i' would be going
back to E8 I think that keeps things a
little bit more compact D6 Pawn gains
another Defender it's going to be better
for white because black is going to be
saddled with an isolated Pawn in the H
file that white can quickly go
after yeah very very
unpleasant Greg had the opportunity to
permanently prevent this resource by
taking on C4 with a pawn you understand
why he took with the Rook that's the
more tempting recapture now he's got to
find a way to keep his kingside Pawn
structure intact I think you should
probably bite the bullet and drop the
Knight back to E8 play GH GH and in some
cases you might have to part ways with
the H6 Pawn of course that's not
necessarily going to end the
game and we see knight8 after a think it
was a sizable think and Greg is still up
by 45 seconds so uh the clock management
has has been in Greg's favor he was
surprised by G6 there thinking that
white had obvious Advantage after GH but
D this also looks Pleasant for Levy he
is just trying to create long-term
weaknesses in Black structure yeah
visually G takes H6 was more tempting
but I think the the key word here is
longterm after F6 sorry I'm uh didn't
play that move intentionally black would
have the weakness of E6 the weakness of
G7 and that Knight would potentially be
able to uncon itself on H5 instead Greg
trying to keep the status quo and saying
yeah you can take on F7 but then you're
going to have to let my Rook get active
I like this more for Greg than I did
earlier and Bishop E3 it was given a
question mark I'm not sure what's so bad
about but Bishop G5 at any moment will
be tempting for Greg to pin this s on
F4 yeah that would be an issue because
the bishop on E3 it was perfectly well
defended on C1 it's no longer on a
defended Square on
E3 well now is there F5 can you play F5
for black and say your G6 Pawn isn't a
strength but a weakness I loved F5
because it would have also involved The
Rook on C4 laterally suddenly the
pressure on F4 would have gotten serious
and Levy falling behind on the clock as
well this is looking not so fun for
white anymore I think you have to start
retreating and he does just that E2 F5
looks perfectly timed and it's so nice
that the Knight on E8 it's fulfilling a
crucial defensive Duty it's guarding the
D6 pawn and it's also guarding the G7
Square taking the stick out of a
potential knight jump to
H5 and I wonder if Greg is looking in
that direction this will be the final
game of the 5minute time control you see
that the match clock has elapsed for the
5 minute plus 1 second increment and he
plays F5 and Sicilian players they need
to be looking at lashing out on the king
side an exclamation point deserve for
that move absolutely the timing of that
move could not have been better Greg has
now firmly taken over the initiative
what was once his strength what was once
the pride of White's position on G6
fixing all of Black's weaknesses is now
one of gu's greatest liabilities after
Bishop takes E3 Black's Rook could slide
over to G5 and suddenly the G Pawn is
hanging the other G Pawn is hanging
Levy's King side is on the verge of
collapse here and then black will play
E5 and get that Bishop out to F5 and go
after the C2 Pawn so there problems on
both sides of the board for Levy you saw
him kind of shake his head before seemed
like he was cracking his neck but it's a
sign that his position is not
particularly good and I don't know what
Greg is shaking his head for now he's
clearly better maybe sort of hearo style
he's disappointed at Levy's play he's
disappointed that Levy didn't make him
defend
longer this is looking like Levy is
going to have to defend for a long time
just to survive this The Rook is under
attack I would slide back one square to
C5 and hit that Knight on H5 trying to
gather that G6 Pawn God Greg has been so
sharp in the last couple of games but
can he keep his foot on the gas pedal I
think the best way to do that is to play
E5 the move that you pointed out Robert
he puts a rook on E5 also interesting
Rook takes E5 he might want to recapture
with a pawn and dislodge this night from
F4 that would pave the way for black to
start munching on these G pawns that's
really clever because he is inviting
double pawns for himself and Levy says
no thank you I'm going move my Rook to
the C file and for Greg yeah you go back
and forth I don't think that's likely at
this stage but how else can you play for
a win you need to push that E Pawn up to
E5 and now it's the question for Levy he
might not want to go back to E3 because
he might be worried about E5 he does go
back to E3 he's fine with the draw here
no question about it Greg puts the other
Rook on E5 don't play Rook C3 now for
obvious reasons goes Rook E1 and maybe
takes and put the Rook on G5 again that
is hilarious that you didn't expect the
G5 Rook to be traded he goes King C7
watch out for Knight D3 that's what Lev
setting up absolutely good awareness by
Greg again The Rook gets to G5 but now
Levy is managing to secure his King side
Rook C3 Rook E1 and suddenly Knight D5
is in the air that King on C7 is super
misplaced but Levy gets passive he only
has 6 seconds on his clock and now he's
trying to double up his Rook he's
defending C2 but Greg's Rooks are
annoyingly active Okay I would
definitely trade one pair of Rooks
that's just going to make Black's
position easier to navigate yeah trade
and play Rook G5 the G6 Pawn finally is
dropping
and a big moment right now he misses it
King to D7 trying to centralize his King
but allowing Levy to control the G5
square and once again Robert the G6 Pawn
has become a strength but he's blundered
Bishop B4 yeah there were some F5 ideas
with Knight takes G7 to follow but
instead the G oh no he's
walking he's walking into everything and
he's just going to end up two pawns down
in the end game it's over me Greg has
been very solid even when he has bad
positions he has not gone down without a
fight and we seen this position the G
Pawn is loose take that pawn take the
second G pawn and your troubles are
mostly over it's not over yet don't miss
a knight Fork whatever you do Greg
cycling around with his rook and
allowing Knight D4 Levy is very
resilient in these types of positions I
would play Knight F5 and Knight H4 and
try to go after that G7 pawn and he does
just that whoa whoa whoa knight6 knight6
yeah he found a way to stop it and
Whit's Knights are tied together and
Knight takes G7 that should do the trick
how many pieces is black up it's a rook
in two pawns for just or not one Pawn
for a knight he could have picked up one
of the knights there with Knight H5 it's
still not over those Knights are so
resilient it's so easy to miss a knight
Fork but he's giving away a knight and
he's losing the game hard to fork with
knights when you don't have them so it's
now a full extra rook and this doesn't
matter when Levy ends up throwing in the
towel because it's the last game of the
5 plus one and look at that Knight B6
Knight C4 and that's resignation and
that is a two-point lead for greet
shotti I know all roads lead to led to
Philadelphia there but Knight A8 Knight
B6 Knight C4 is a sexy way to end that
game it's a frustrating one for Levy you
can sense the frustration as he goes
down by two points the one piece of
encouragement for Levy this is shades of
2021 Robert and we know how that match
ended in 2021 Greg Jihadi had the lead
after the 5+ one and the 3+ one but in
the bullet Levy was King he won 8 to two
against Greg in 2021 so we know that he
still has a chance and da before we head
a break what does levy have to do
differently in the quicker time control
he needs to perform better in time
scrambles I think that was maybe the
biggest X Factor he's gotten everything
that he could ask for out of the opening
maybe a different line of the carocon
with black but he has to maintain his
composure when both sides get under 20
seconds I am so impressed with the way
that Greg has handled himself with under
20 seconds he has done the better job of
being the better player th far well old
Greg learning new tricks he is now up
two points and Levy he was great in
title Tuesday beating Ali R of fua
recently but did you know that even if
you're not titled there's still a
tournament for you Untitled Tuesdays is
open to all Untitled players compete in
Untitled Tuesday every week and put your
skills to the test amongst your
chess.com Community anyone is eligible
to play in the weekly Untitled Tuesday
tournaments so use the command Untitled
in chat to learn how to play enjoy
yourselves each and every Tuesday just
like hiar Nakamura Magnus Carlson and
more do you have a chance to play and
compete against the community so on that
note we are going to take a break
community members watching give us your
predictions will it be Greg shot will be
Levy Rosman this is the I am not GM
Spees Championship brought to you by
chess.com
[Music]
welcome to check with mates the only
podcast by chess pieces for chess pieces
I'm a rook and I'm a pawn let me ask you
this you ever feel like you're
undervalued absolutely everyone's like
oh pawns they can only move one square
they can't go backwards maybe we don't
want to go backwards you know maybe
we're focused on the future yeah I feel
that sometimes I wonder why we're even
protecting a king he wasn't elected
through a democratic process maybe I
want to be king dude I think about that
every day yeah okay real quick shout out
to our sponsor hello fresh I don't use
them because I'm a chess piece but I'm
sure they're
great chess again no this is spell chess
do I dare read the instructions or
should I go in without reading them I
didn't read the rules this man is just
blundering what basically it's normal
chess but there're two spells jump and
freeze the free freeze is applied to a
3X3 area man this game is what freeze
here night check boom that's M oh that's
that's that's incredible stuff oh oh
freeze wait I froze my cor a jump spell
which allows you to jump over a piece
and I'm setting up a win oh then black
would just freeze
me then I make a double threat you don't
have any freezes left so if
here this is too hard wait once I get
the hang of this we're going to be
winning so many games though I can't
block with any of those pieces but I can
use this this and then
this raise this and then go
here yay I won let's go cannot take my
Bishop he can I'll take my
Bish it's a nice feeling when you start
understanding the game and you win oh
they resigned I'm not even li I think
I'm one of the greatest spell chest
players to ever played spell chest that
was fun I'm enjoying
[Music]
this
he
[Music]
d
he
[Music]
you've seen the speed Chess
Championship now it's time for the rest
of us to get a turn with no Grand
Masters allowed it's the I'm not a GM
speed Chess
Championship watch your favorite chess
personalities duke it out in chess.com
exciting speed chess
format there will be brilliancies GL
stacking another P Bishop C3 and Rook a
one oh Rook a one there will be blunder
no no he fell for it 16 players are
fighting for a chance at the eight
player knockout see old rivalries this
is how long new
foes with a $155,000 prize pool who will
take home the crown this year and that
is the match the imcc starts right
now
and we are back here at the I am not GM
speed Chess Championship it's Levy
Rosman versus Greg shahadi right now
Greg chiadi leads by two points over
Levy but da it's been quite a good fight
between these two it's been an amazing
fight between these two from the
perspective of entertainment from the
perspective of game quality and from the
perspective of all the interesting
opening openings and middle games and
time scrambles that we have seen thus
far Robert Greg could not be happier
with the outcome of the 5minute portion
plus two 4 and 1/2 2 and A2 is a great
start for him especially considering he
lost the first game he trailed at a
couple points in the longest time
control portion but D now we're heading
into the three plus one the time control
gets shorter that's usually good news
for Levy Rosman completely impossible to
predict what happens here normally that
would be good news it would be good news
in light of Levy's performance in the
bullet segment which he crushed in their
2021 match but at the risk of being a
broken record the way that Greg has
handled the time scrambles the way that
he's acquitted himself when the players
were under 10 seconds I think bod's
really really well for his chances in
the subsequent two segments Levy needs
to make some changes he needs to settle
his nerves it feels like he's been the
much more nervous and the much more
jumpy player in that first segment I
felt that ever since the first time
scramble between the two Levy did win on
time in that game but his moves were not
coordinated the way his play usually is
but all all that said he's down by two
points Greg has been playing well Levy
has history on his side he won a match
against Greg Jihadi back in 2021 when
trailing by several points heading into
bullet so he knows that he is capable of
mounting a
comeback man Greg Greg is always moving
it's he's either moving his mouth he's
always talking or eating he's never just
motionless well he's never motionless
and he's never emotionless we've seen
his emotions on full display he's
laughing he's bewildered he's wondering
what he was looking at but look at Levy
it does seem like he is working to calm
himself down just sitting there taking a
sip just trying to focus on the upcoming
games and that adjustment D let's talk
about that a little bit when you go from
playing a bunch of five minute base time
control games to three minute how hard
is it to change your speed very and you
see players overcompensating all the
time as we kick off the three-minute
portion Greg will have the white pieces
in game one we see that overcompensation
happen and players going too quickly
that can be just as damaging as doing as
doing the opposite thing and treating
the three-minute portion like it's the
five minute portion we saw que D2 there
that's a Cheesy trap Knight bd7 would
have gotten made let me show that really
quickly after Queen E2 there's a very
famous game Caris against Arlovski where
black automatically played the move
Knight B to D7 now Robert Knight C5
Knight G5 Knight F6 Knight C3 Knight G
nope Knight D6 and that ladies and
gentlemen is a Checkmate that everybody
should have in their attacking Arsenal
didn't that also happen in a game where
I think someone read 2000 was playing as
Richard report and you know that's a
dream come true for a nonprofessional
player I get to play Richard report and
I'm pretty sure the game ended just like
that with that quick Checkmate so it's
something you need to watch out for it
still has happened even in the 21st
century and even in the 21st century
apparently you put your Bishop in front
of your King Pawn your dark s Bishop
seems seems to suffer but Greg is taking
a page out of Levy's book putting that
Queen over on H4 I had an experience
like that in my very first Simo against
Boris spasy uh in 2004 I was rated 1500
so excited I mean I get to play spasky
I'm completely Star Struck my only goal
is to last longer than the opening he
plays a bishop G5 F4 kner and I
accidentally castled kingside and the
moment he sacrificed his Bishop on H6 on
like move 12 the tears like they fell on
the black king I started crying because
I knew that I wasn't going to last over
20 moves but that photo of me resigning
against spasy 2004 it's still on the
wall behind me people can't see it
because of my camera angle but I might
bring it and show it to people one of
these days love that don't love the
result for you but love that memory
because playing against a legend of the
game that's clearly inspiring to all
youngsters and right now Bishop back to
E2 this doesn't feel so inspiring to me
that Bishop jumped out to D3 back to E2
neither King is Castle
should we tell all the audience to look
away from this game because that's not
how we're taught to play chess we are
certainly not and we're not taught to
give up pawns like they're I don't know
like they're nothing Bishop F6 and queen
F6 is a pawn now that's clearly a
Sacrifice by Levy what does he want in
return for the pawn he wanted to play
Rook G8 and from an objective standpoint
Robert I think black would have had
enough for the pawn there would have
been pressure on G2 there was the
possibility of a skewer so Greg wants
none of it is Levy actually going for D2
no he's not no that would be overly
ambitious to put it kindly but what Levy
is going for once again is a position
where he is a knight his opponent is a
bishop but look at that Bishop on F3 as
you like to say it's biting on granite
it's staring into a brick wall a solid
Pawn formation from B7 to C6 from F7 to
E6 so that Bishop it's not really doing
well on their
diagonals yeah somewhere John
Bartholomew is having a field he's
looking at this and saying man this is
this has always been my dream you get
these types of positions out of the
scandy you get them out of the caran and
it's very important for Levy once again
not to let greed get the better of him
Bishop takes C6 check was a very
instructive idea to remember so Levy
councils he coordinates his Rooks he's
got a big time Advantage so far Robert
this is going exactly the way that he
wants it to and Greg just keeps moving
his Bishops around the bishop went from
D3 to E2 to capture on F3 that Bishop
went to B2 to C3 back to B2 we haven't
seen a plan from Greg just yet and still
the engine says White's doing perfectly
fine why is that the bishop pair now D4
and black is a bit restricted it's
cramped you need to come up with some
sort of active plan and one active plan
could involve starting to shove the
queenside pawns forward you could even
play B5 in this position the C6 pawn it
can be captured but that allows the C
file to open and for Black's Queen to
infiltrate C2 I think Lev is deciding
whether he wants to play aggressively or
sort of keep the status quo given his
time Advantage I would slow roll this
with Rook D7 rook ad8 and in all my
Blitz and bullet experience I really
dislike playing this structure from the
white side because I never know like
when to push C4 when to push A4 and then
suddenly when you start pushing your
pawns you feel like you're getting
overextended well we see a knight on B6
so we like our Pawn on B3 and C4 takes
further pawns squares excuse me away
from the Knight but it leaves D4
vulnerable so I would not be playing C4
but C three here I know that makes my
Bishop look a bit silly but it also
makes most of Black's setup look a bit
silly so I think C3 is a move that you
can play confidently from the white side
as black is ready to double Rooks in the
defile and the ideal setup I think would
involve playing C3 and then deploying
your dark squir Bishop to A3 to control
some of these important dark squares for
that to happen though you would need the
C Pawn protected so Rook D3 is a nice
multi-purpose move he might be preparing
to double his Rooks and overprotect the
D4 for pun now you have to stay alert
Knight F4 Big Fork threat you should go
G3 and Greg when he beat alen in their
Armageddon game he actually blundered a
fork just like that he plays Queen D2
here offering a queen trade there's no
way black is worse in the ensuing
endgame you trade and you play C5
because the D4 Pawn is pinned he instead
chooses Rook to d8 and now white
successfully plays C3 da it may look
even I see the clock Greg under 30
seconds I am a bit worried for him for
sure but see3 was a nice move one step
on the road to recovery it's an awkward
looking Pawn structure but the D4 Pawn
must be kept protected at all costs and
he's found the opportunity to get his
Bishop to A3 Levy drops his own Bishop
back to E7 we might get a knight versus
Bishop situation Levy is going to keep
massaging this at infinum and that's
what worries me Greg is going to have to
keep reacting to all of these threats
and that's going to cause this clock to
keep dwindling take the Knight on D5 is
what I would do if I were Greg because
the Knight has an advantage over bishop
and I like Knight C7 by Levy the Knight
can jump from color complex to color
complex a bishop has inherent
limitations because it only moves on its
own diagonal I do like the expansion on
the king side for Greg but I like the
speed from Levy very much so Knight F6
he's kind of shuffling back and forth
and poking and prodding speaking of
poking and pring Greg induces a weakness
with A6 if he wants to get ambitious
potentially he could send his be on down
the board and try to create pressure on
the queen side I don't think he's going
to do that though he's managed to
equalize the clock though and maybe B4
should be prophylactically at some point
in order to stop C5 maybe there's a
difference two years can make and that's
that Greg is an even better player under
the duress of time trouble right now
he's playing excellent moves and all of
his moves have had purpose Knight F5
doesn't threaten anything he just drops
his Rook back to maybe avoid any Forks
to just play something a bit random but
I don't see what black is threatening
and Levy is playing for a win he
declined the repetition there Greg is
clearly fine with the draw his moves are
indicating that he's treading water and
there we go C5 buckle your seat belts
folks and C4 the Knight can SL slink
into B4 dark Square domination for black
and I would put the pawns on dark
squares B6 and A5 just so you don't have
to worry about potential blunder great
stuff by Knight C2
Fork another one and again and he finds
it Knight D3 you take on E one with
check oh my gosh Knight takes E1 check
Levy misses it the first time second
times the charm and now he needs to just
convert this easy extra Exchange but
with 5 Seconds F4 F4 and Bishop D5
Bishop D5 and then and then F5 coming
for white oh he would have had practical
chances there to build a fortress still
not over one second F5 for White and the
light squares are under White's control
the black king is not completely out of
the woods but that's a good move though
but you're going to get a pair of Rooks
off the board I think and that's going
to spell disaster for white yes getting
Rook E5 in was critical for black and
unless white can go for this G Pawn
which I don't even see how you
successfully do he
did but he's going to get
ladder ah nice job by Lev
there and king oh it could have taken on
B3 because C5 wasn't available as the
bishop was hanging but this of course
does the trick Levy playing with an
abundance of C just making sure that
there isn't even an iota of counterplay
here and the final trick there by Greg
King D3 hitting the rook and he's just
going to stall the clock out so if I
were Greg I would want more games in the
longer time controls just because we saw
in their history and that Levy wins cut
cutting deficit to one point that he
does better in Blitz than in bullet
against Levy so I probably would have
resigned earlier but it is early in the
match to be speaking this metag game
strategy I agree and I what I liked
about that game from Levy's perspective
is that he was in control he got the
kind of position that he wanted out of
the opening it was definitely a top seat
tur endgame but Levy had the easier
position the entire time he went for the
win instead of taking the repetition and
he spotted the fork not the first time
but the second time good tactical
awareness good play and time pressure
and it seemed like Levy was just a lot
more in control of his emotions in
control of himself psychologically as
the clock dwindled down closer to zero
and Greg goes back to this opening that
you quite clearly stated that you don't
like and he gives himself double e-
pawns which aren't the end of the world
sometimes we see double pawns we
overreact and you often said that pawn
structure is overrated in chess the pawn
E6 takes away the D5 Square from the
White Knight that's the good news and
the Bishop from f8 can slide out to G7
at some moment and make use of a very
nice long diagonal for sure you just
need a couple of moves to whip up
chances against White's King but right
now you've got bigger fish to fry you
need to guard the C6 Pawn he does it by
dropping his Knight back to d8 with
Tempo that Bishop is going to find a
very nice home on B3 it's also
protecting the the king adding that
extra layer of security and taking the
sting out of Black's pressure against C2
I like Knight oh I was say I like Knight
D7 to C5 but that will hang the E7 Pawn
so the big idea for black you can't even
get away with it and
Levy Queen no oh D6 isn't hanging
there's a bishop on
D2 the queen is trapped there what the
heck wa did G5 what was there oh wait no
I played it oh my gosh you mous
no he finds it this actually we see the
EV bar it doesn't react so we're like
okay that's just a move but I just want
to highlight how great Greg's tactical
awareness has been in some critical
moments Queen takes E7 I said it out
loud that just drops a pawn but Bishop
F6 traps the queen because the bishop on
D2 is in the rook's path otherwise the
queen could take on D6 the queen can't
take there it can't take on E6 cuz the
Knight on d8 that Queen is trapped on E7
it's so easy to miss one of these dies
cuz you're not used to Bishop on D2
obstructing a rook like this and after
Knight B5 at a very minimum black could
just take the queen and When the Smoke
Clears black is simply up a minor piece
Levy spots it but the point of Knight D7
isn't just a set of trap as you
indicated Robert you're also trying to
seek greener pastures with your knight
you're getting it to E5 or you're
getting it to C5 we see the immediate
Knight B5 from Levy but is that just an
impulsive one move threat does he have a
clear followup to that move Bishop A4
that looks very flimsy because of Knight
C 5 I think Levy might be losing the
thread here a little bit I don't like
this position at all if he plays Bishop
C3 trying to trade dark Square Bishops I
think black shuts that down with Pawn to
E5 and says I'm sorry where do you think
your knight on B5 is backtracking to you
don't have C3 you don't have D4 and it
just feels like Black's pieces are
flowing more easily that Knight is
coming to C5 as we mentioned this is
exactly what's happening I would play E5
very quickly if I regre shotti E5 is
such a nice move and notice queen queen
takes E7 still possible but that pawn
still Untouchable because of that very
same Bishop F6 mechanism so the
situation on the queen side has changed
but the defensive mechanism that guards
the E7 Pawn indirectly has not E5
excellent move I think white will be
forced to play A4 and drop the Knight
ignominiously back to A3 that's the only
way that you're going to save the Knight
if you're Levy well actually that line
E5 Queen takes E7 the D6 Pawn is hanging
there so maybe bishop f8 is necessary
but the point still stands you know your
exact point still Rings through that the
Knight on B5 is loose so you can't just
go Pawn grabbing if you are Levy but
Greg is dropping precipitously low on
the clock so he trades on C3 first I
happy about it and his position now is
not the side for Choice his position
just doesn't have teeth and E5 is an
excellent followup Levy sensing that
Greg Miss played they're forcing him
into Irish pawns along the E file now he
can start attacking them by getting his
Rook to E1 and forget about the tactics
Robert just positionally strategically
White's got better pieces White's got an
excellent Bishop that's exerting
long-term pressure on E6 the queen is
hitting E7 and The Rook is going to be
hitting E5 so he's actually pressuring
all three of Black's tripled pawns and
he gives himself an isolated Pawn with
that move it was given a question mark
by the computer but we understand it
he's trying to go after the E7 Pawn open
the D file open the f file and here I
think Greg has to get defensive and you
know what give up one of your pawns at
the right moment that's what strong
players are taught that if your position
is uncomfortable and you're up a pawn
it's okay to shed that extra material to
improve your remaining position so I
think Knight C6 at the right moment will
be a good idea from black a great idea
you have to get active even if it comes
at the cost of one of your pawns I
honestly think calling the E6 Pawn a
pawn is an insult to actual pawns so
Greg says take all that you can get
along the E file as long as I get a
little bit more active I'm happy Levy
says okay I'm gonna help myself the all
you can eat buffet has opened but so has
a direct line of fire against White's
King Rook d8 Bish Bishop D5 a good move
Rook d8 another one Queen takes H7 is
available but after queen as you're
pointing out E6 it sneakily wins a piece
so Queen cannot take that pawn there
Levy should not be fooled he instead
moves his Rook to the other open file a
great choice from Gotham chess okay Rook
out one now Levy is ready to help
himself to the king side PS but not
quite yet not quite yet Queen D3 is a
threat and he moves his King to A2 black
is really missing like one more minor
piece these pawns on C3 and A3 are doing
such a nice job of restricting Black's
Knight Levy is a couple more careful
moves away from consolidating his
decisive advantage and watch out for
Rook takes D5 at the right moment it
could give black a lot of checks against
the white king and Bishop takes C6 Pawn
takes C6 is forced Queen takes E7 will
be Levy's followup he'll give up his
Rook on F2 to take that Rook on d8 with
check excellent tactical awareness if
Levy can spot Queen takes C7 now Rook D1
there very tempting but you would have
gotten latter checkmated much like in
the previous game Queen E7 check now
Levy starting to mop up some of these
pawns but these end games can be
notoriously difficult to win because
there's always Perpetual check in the
air and if black can can create his own
pass Pawn then the position gets a
little bit more
double-sided and these positions it's
not just about Pond quantity but quality
if for example the H2 Pawn drops and
black and quickly play G5 like right now
actually how are you going to protect
both E4 and H2 you might have to go
Queen G3 instead Greg going after
Perpetual Shack with Queen C4 can Levy
find a queen trade here that would end
the game immediately a queen trade would
be winning there are no more checks so
he pushes Pawn to H4 and now E5 for
white I don't see how black is going to
defend this queen F5 only move I thought
Queen D6 was a good try there but Levy
adds an extra layer of security to his
King there's Queen D6 can he play Maybe
A4 here but he's going after C4 and then
A4 is coming you're right two seconds
he's barely getting his moves off his
Levy and he can't pre-move either
because he doesn't know where Black's
King is going to go he's trying to gain
a little bit of time with his
checks and he goes back to De
a4b
mechanism Queen B4 excellent spot for
White's Queen but C5 and he drops the
pawn with check Queen D5 traed Queens
Queen D6 he forced the Queens off in
that
stat oh
oh what a dirty little move by Greg you
got to try everything in your bag and
from Levy so smart not to pre there he
wins he ties the match up 4 and a half
to 4 and a half but he didn't pre-move
because had he pre moved that G5 Push by
Greg would have actually stolen the game
in his favor and we're back to the kacan
and to an even score I love that Spirit
by Greg listen I do that myself in
casual 30 second games but Levy wasn't
born yesterday today this is one of
those lessons that you learn the hard
way the first time you miss it you learn
not to pre-move uh when there's an
increment and not to pre-move when your
opponent has one of those dirty Pawn
pushes uh when ignored that could
produce a queen and that could produce a
lot of tears I had a very da yet thought
and I I can't believe I'm going to say
it out loud but preo Levy sounds like a
pretty famous author so uh you know now
that's going to be in my head uh for the
future so uh we see Levy yeah exactly so
Rook G8 played attacking this Pawn on G2
you have double pawns but inherit to
having double pawns means you have an
open file so The Rook attacks the pawn
and watch out for sacrifices on that G3
Square I don't think white is castl on
King side in this game yeah I agree I
thought you said
sacrifices that would be a pretty nice
term I don't think we're going to see
any sacrifices just yet we're going to
see a bishop trade on D6 and I really
really like this Pawn structure for
black this moroi bind is pawns on D5 and
F5 what did they do well not not only do
they clamp down on the center and they
prevent moves like G4 but they're also
creating a major stronghold on e4 and I
think Levy is going to jump to E4 right
about now and I think for Greg you
should not trade Knights you should say
drop your knight back to D3 because that
helps you keep control of the center
trading Knights I think that black is
happy to take back even with the B Pawn
to play C5 and A5 and expand over there
on the queen side so it looks like black
has complete control with the Knight on
e4 and
whoa Pawn sacrifice can you not grab it
cuz F3 at the end that was anything but
a regular move using some tactics to
protect the E4 Knight Knight take now I
would take on E5 Robert just to
eliminate The Outpost and slink back to
C7 you are under no obligation to take
the pawn on E5 great awareness by Levy
and Rook C8 the F2 Pawn is hanging Greg
has to be careful to keep his position
intact here and there's nothing gular
about it I mean this is a weird position
so I would play Rook D4 I would block
that he plays it I blocked the Queen's
path and da you have to be careful
because at some moment when you're not
looking out for it that H7 Pawn will be
loose so if white plays a move like Rook
F1 there could be a queen H5 coming your
way and even G4 Pawn pushes like giving
up your G Pawn to open up the H file for
The Rook Rook takes E4 by the way is a
very big threat and what a devilish
threat that night on e4 earlier uh was
more comfortable than a well-fitting
pair of Levis or should I say levies but
now that Knight on e4 starting to feel a
little bit uncomfortable you got to get
that he missed he missed it he missed it
he missed it and did you see Greg's face
he's like I cannot believe it but I will
gladly take
it oh my goodness that Queen on B6
Robert l p d o Levy pieces drop off and
you see Levy look at the camera he just
shakes his head he is disgusted by
allowing the that tactic and even though
he's the one who just tied up the score
he probably feels like he's in bad
momentum because he just had an
egregious blunder he just didn't see it
coming that was disturbing it's not like
blundering something on a side of the
board where nothing's happening Greg
played Queen E3 to set up this tactic
right if you're Levy you have to see the
standoff between the Queens you have to
ask yourself what does my opponent want
why did he put the queen on E3 big
uncharacteristic blender by Levy and
he's going to go down by one point once
again
and we are nearing the halfway point of
the 3 minute plus 1 second increment
time control so maybe Levy would get a
much needed break unless this game ends
quickly then I think we will have
another one before the players get that
halftime so Greg now that he's up a
knight for just the pawn make that a
knight for no pawns he is just trying to
be a bit careful but Queen D7 followed
by Rook to B7 I feel like the seventh
rank is just falling
apart yeah it is the queen on A2 its
power is totally circumscribed by the
Knight which is controlling the A1
Square the Knight can be a very powerful
defensive piece when it surrounds your
king it can completely restrict even the
strongest enemy forces you don't even
have to rush Queen C6 Queen A4 would be
the sort of Russian school boy method he
gets his King onto the safest Square on
the board he wants Rook A1 to trap the
queen oh I didn't even see that well you
came up with an idea to trade Queens he
said why trade when I can win it and D4
looks to be the only move for black and
white shuts down the diagonal with C4
Rook A1 to follow that should be game
over I think Levy is just going to throw
that pawn down to D3 if you want you can
play Knight takes D4 what you don't want
to do is spend the rest of your time
trying to stubbornly find a way to trap
the queen but kudos to Greg and look at
that Rook on G6 just completely out of
the game shut down by his own Pawn on
E6 wow and what a needed game for Greg
shahadi after losing two in a row Levy
still upset about that night blunder and
and here we see Greg he is just trading
off that black queen for the two Rooks
he is up a queen of Knight for two Rooks
and Levy just doesn't want anymore he
resigns and he is still shaking his head
as the commentators say resigns without
awaiting the opponent's next move or
resigned on his own turn that just means
you're so disgusted with your position
you don't want a single second uh of
this game to continue and I feel like
we've seen this opening before but I
don't want to jump the gun here this
looks Vaguely Familiar to me
what about this earlier H6 now so Greg
at least is getting different types of
positions even if you've preferred them
from Levy's side and I have to say that
getting this black game in before the
break should be good news for Greg I may
eat my words and Levy may play a
masterpiece but considering that Levy is
frustrated with that peie blunder I
wanted that extra game before Levy gets
a timeout yeah Greg is sticking with
this opening I think it's a pretty
admirable choice because regardless of
the objective evaluation he's actually
scored pretty well in this line and like
we talked about in the 5-minute portion
as we see a kind of strange reaction by
Greg to the move Queen G5 it gets more
frustrating and frustrating when you
keep getting good positions and then
can't convert them that has been Greg's
strategy and I'm all for it and I'm all
for F5 we saw it work in his favor in a
previous game he's trading Queens first
but F5 you UND double your pawns you
open up that dark Square Bishop Knight
D5 Knight B I see what you're doing
you're going for a cheeky Little Fork on
C7 I will either play King to d8 or Rook
to B8 I'm going to avoid your little
Fork this is all happening I'm starting
to like this position more and more for
black the longer it sits in front of
us I agree I mean we've seen Greg push
F5 before and this is the great thing
about this Sicilian Pawn structure it's
very weak to begin with right it's very
visually unappealing but it's easy to
GRE I was going to say regenerate
unfortunately it's regenerate not
regenerate I was going to say regenerate
the pawn structure it's like an octopus
that grows new tentacles and out Black's
Pawn structure actually looks really
really nice once you've managed to UND
double your pawns and here's a big
question though do you take this bishop
on D3 I love to move Bishop D7 I was
asking it knowing what my answer was
going to be because when you have the
two Bishops Advantage the key to that uh
sentence is
the two Bishops because without a bishop
you might not be able to control that
color complex keeping both of them on
the board means that square like F5 is
better under Black's control well said
Bishop on D7 very important defensive
piece I like Levy's last move C3 making
sure that this bishop on G7 that its
influence over the game is minimized
also H5 beautiful Square for White's
Knight no I like the way Levy's handling
this I mean the opening isn't as
strategic or I should say aggressive as
levie wanted now it is strategic that's
what I was getting at and Greg has shown
a tendency to liquidate into end games
he prefers a what in the world oh no you
know what he did he clicked his King no
no yeah he clicked his King and clicked
his rook and wanted to put something on
G8 but it wasn't his King he wanted to
play Rook G8 I guess yeah sometimes you
click one piece and you click another
piece and those two pieces happen to be
the king and rook and there is a legal
move that involves the king and Rook it
it's happen to all of us now how would
you assess the damage is this a disaster
well it is a disaster if you're allow
Rook G4 Checkmate but you could move the
Rook over to d8 and I actually think
amazingly that black is not doing as
badly as Greg might think and well he
played F5 Because he believes that black
was doing badly that move earned a
question mark and the reason why is look
at the problem down the defile you were
right to suggest Rook F to d8 King to f8
Scurry back towards the center now this
bishop will go away from the D3 Square
the D6 Pawn will be in trouble the
bishop on D7 behind it and also G4 if
you want to play on the king side you
can play in both directions yeah the
problems on the king side it's in the
center and another issue is that even if
you don't lose the D6 Pawn if you are
forced from Black's perspective to play
the move D5 you create a massive hole on
the E5 score and White's Knights are
perfectly poised to exploit that you
could play Bishop E5 D5 drop the Knight
back to D3 and then occupy the Outpost
with one of the knights so black is
tactically worse he's also positionally
much worse it reminds me of the first
game of the match where Levy showcased
some great preparation then he was able
to plant a knight on E5 in a pawn
structure not too dissimilar from this
one and here we see C4 the bishop on D7
is loose black can't take on C4 you lose
your Bishop A6 can be played but then
you have to think about the tactics
after C takes D5 and then it looks like
White's position is better and Black's
structure is falling apart and Greg
tries to keep the center closed even at
the cost of a pawn now a big big
question for Levy does he take on C6 it
can be a little bit scary to allow black
to open up the B file especially because
that Bishop on G7 will ultimately have
its moment in the Sun and I think Greg's
survival chances depend partially on his
ability to activate this bishop if he
can keep that Bishop alive and he can
keep it operating on the long diagonal
he's always going to have practical
chances against White's King G4 by Levy
feels like he's going on the wrong side
well he's trying to have his cake and
eat it too he's playing everywhere and
look at this E5 black strikes in the
center and if you take on F5 the bishop
takes with check and suddenly it's the
white king that is in danger The Rook on
H4 is not as menacing as you would like
in whoa he decides to take there but
Knight B4 next
E4 yeah E4 looks
great this just feels awful for white
all of a sudden how did this turn around
in the span of like two moves and Robert
you can't play Bishop C6 and Knight
takes D4 either cuz Rook d8 the end you
pin and win the Knight in the center and
that Rook on H4 it doesn't actually
threaten anything cuz the bishop on F5
dominates
it 24 G4 was a terrible move by Levy
he's playing as though there are queen
still on the board and he might not have
a king on the board pretty soon black
might have a queen on the board I Am
with You Knight B4 E2 Knight C2 check
and thank you for the new queen that
looks almost forced and I think Levy
will have to trade pawns play Knight F3
and hope that his Knight on F3 can stop
that pawn from promoting absolutely have
to play Knight F3 and black has to mount
an allout assault in the center I would
play Rook B to d8 try to reclaim the
defile and this is exquisite technique
by Greg he knows that he can't pass this
opportunity up and here comes E2 right
now if he plays E2 he wins the game
because Knight C2 is a fork if he swap
works and D The Rook lands on D1
afterwards and he's just going in this
move order it should still be more than
enough lovely play by Greg Levy has to
keep the Rook on the first Rank and
Bishop G4 striking at the other side
threatening to eliminate the Knight on F
three and Paving the way for the
promotion of the pawn and now you to
take this Pawn oh he low a queen so he's
down a full Rook so this game is
officially in the books and it looked
like Levy would tie the score once more
it's Greg shahadi once again leading by
two despite the mouse slip despite
castling right into the eye of the storm
I think Levy's expression says it all
that's such a frustrating way to lose
and Greg he regenerates that two-point
lead
and Levy you see him biting his shirt
it's frustrating for him that extra game
that was included before the break it's
definitely hurt Levy there we were
talking about how it was good for Greg
as Levy remained frustrated he blundered
that night two games ago and I'm
actually being told there is no break I
was wrong so I'm talking about a Midway
break sorry about that we're going to
continue the chest doesn't stop that's
bad news for Levy absolutely 20 more
minutes left in regulation time then of
course we have that allout bullet
segment where Levy came back in their
2021 match but this feels different it
feels like Greg is handling things so
much better in time pressure situations
than he did a couple of years ago he's
shaking his head though I'm not even
going to try to puzzle out what he's
thinking he's up by two in this match
he's playing excellent chess and he's
repeating that weird carocon line that
they had in the first game of the
segment it's weird for many reasons the
bishop on E6 and speaking of weird Greg
is trying to trade off Queens every
single game it feels like with the black
pieces he's trying to trade queens now
with the white pieces he's trying to
swwa them so he might be pressing in the
end game thinking he's got the better
chances I don't know it feels like black
is just so so solid here I would put the
yeah Bishop F5 E6 and Levy's already
displayed uh excellent understanding of
this type of Pawn structure in their
first three-minute game so I'm a little
bit puzzled that Greg chose to repeat
this
line okay Levy is in a stable position
no weaknesses that I can see if I'm Greg
I'm playing Knight H4 Now give me the
bishop pair he does just that he is
saying that I will call that a plus even
if the engine says it's perfectly
level and we see the position with the
bishop dropping back to G6 so you could
take it on G6 but there's no reason to
rush so F3 is the move from Greg saying
if you want to go Bishop H5 I'll push my
Pawn up to attack your bishop and force
it back to the square it came from so I
think that this position is perfectly
reasonable for black Levy shouldn't be
too concerned about the position but I
think he's considering the past more
than anything and sometimes when we're
playing game after game without a break
we start dwelling we start thinking what
could have been instead of focusing on
the here
now
we've seen so many matches in the SEC
across the years decided when players
just can't push those painful memories
of the previous few games out of their
mind now what do we make of this end
game White's got the bishop pair but
because of how solid Black's Pawn
structure is and because of how hard it
is to find a good spot for the light squ
Bishop I think the effect of this dark
of this bishop bear is minimized I would
almost Play Bishop takes F6 hunker down
and try to make a draw here I I don't
like White's position but Bishop takes
F6 is one of those hard moves to play
because you see all these dark Square
weaknesses and he does take on D6 saying
I'll have my Bishop against your knight
I'm with you regardless black is better
here white doesn't have open lines for
The Rook if you bring a rook to E1 good
you're staring into a E6 Pawn that's
well defended but the Rook on h8 and The
Rook on D6 are much more powerful and
you could push your Pawn up to A5 okay
congratulations you don't have a queen
on the board so black can just stop the
progress of that pawn with A6 and and
even laterally attack that pawn with
Rook H5 Levy chooses to focus on the
defile I think a good move here would be
G5 clamping down on some of these dark
squares very very unpleasant stuff for
Greg here one thing that I would be
looking at at the right moment is H4 and
G4 H5 maneuver for White and the reason
I'm doing that is I want to develop my
Rook but instead of in the center over
on the flank he goes Rook e one that's a
completely sensible move he can play
Rook e two he's just playing this
completely solidly and Levy doesn't seem
super ambitious right now I think he
just wants to hold but I'm not liking
the way that he's doing that white could
now play H4 your move Robert and an
additional benefit would have would have
been that the light squ Bishop would
have finally had a home on H3 instead
Greg kind of curling up into a ball I
would still play the move H4 just so you
don't have the headache of having to
constantly worry about that H Pawn being
in the line of fire of Black's rook and
maybe now's the time and it is for A5 H4
in the near future and once you play F4
after Pawn takes F4 not only is the E
file open the G file will open up and
that G6 Pawn sticks out I do not like
Black's position anymore and Levy he had
many opportunities even on the previous
move he could have pushed his g- Pawn up
to G5 and established that long-term
Target on H4 it feels like he's
floundering a little bit Yeah I think
he's still upset about the previous
games the look on his face it's not
about this position although I don't
think that black should be particularly
happy I don't think he should be sad and
you see Greg move with his Bishop he up
15 plus seconds right now I don't see a
plan for needs to find a home for this
there is a convoluted and long-term plan
getting this Knight over to B8 I think
Levy should take the repetition here I
think there's no need for black to get
over ambitious plenty of time left in
the match and a good solid wise decision
by Levy just to stabilize the match pull
out that half point and give yourself
some more recovery time and a chance
with the white pieces you stop the
bleeding and that's what all strong
players are taught to do that in the
position of that nature they didn't know
who was slightly better who was slightly
worse but they realized that trying to
make progress would have required some
risk speaking of risk what is this
opening that we're seeing uh Levy now
has the white pieces he's choosing a
trpovski it looks like black is
underdeveloped I don't remember who it
was it might have been hikaro but in one
of the SEC interviews one of the players
mentioned that there's a particular
satisfaction that you derive from
forcing your opponent to change is
opening Choice like you keep playing the
same line and the first player to Flinch
uh his opponent earns a kind of
psychological Victory and the first
player to Flinch was Levy Le Levy
refrains from that Knight C3 variation
now it's not necessarily because he
didn't like the positions maybe he just
wants to get something fresh but still
it's got to feel pretty validating for
Greg for his opening choices to
ultimately reward him of course and you
see this type of position that he has
now it's one where it's not just White
having all the fun I think that in those
previous games Greg was able to keep it
competitive but it was white who was
controlling the shots here we see that
black can call some shots of his own B5
is on the agenda that Black Knight on D7
will hop out to E5 perhaps now the
bishop on C8 stares into a more open
diagonal and F4 will not be possible for
white because the G4 Square become black
for the taking so I do like how this
position has started for black yeah
conceptually I like Black's position
Greg is also a very Dynamic player and
these types of benoni positions are
really really good in Blitz because you
track them with a computer and the
computer always gives white an advantage
just because he has more space and well
the computer is very prejudiced against
the Kings Indian and the Bon I am not
happy about that I will be writing the
stockfish team momentarily but look at
this with your own eyes from a practical
perspective Black's got so much play on
all sides of the board Queen side you've
got the B file Center you can play E6 on
demand King side you can stick a knight
on G4 feels like White's position is
much hard to handle practically speaking
with minutes on the clock there is one
idea that I tend to like in these
positions for white but usually the
Pawn's not on H4 and meaning your king
side won't be totally safe but what I
was going to say is Rook A2 Pawn B3 you
know just trying to use the a file to
your advantage and shut down Black's
counterplay the problem is as soon as
you play B3 black plays C4 and prize
open the queen side and that diagonal by
the way the bishop on G7 that's waiting
it's lurking in the shadows hoping it
opens up up to give him some huge play
absolutely and Bishop D7 is a nice
prudent developing move by Greg inducing
B3 I think you called it Robert I think
this is a golden opportunity for black
to play C4 and you don't want to
procrastinate because white threatens to
bring the Knight back to B2 tempo for
Tempo things are working out for Greg
here did you see Greg when he made the
move C4 he just said let's go for it he
kind of waved his hand he wasn't even
calculating fully it was his intuition
and his intuition is fantastic look at
this position black is clearly the side
for choice I feel like Magnus does that
kind of hand wve and when he does it you
know you're screwed like okay I'm just
going to play it but and then he plays
it and you know you're lost and that is
often what happens and you see in this
position Greg he's looking he's like do
I push that c Pawn again can I get away
with C3 should I do something else that
Knight on G5 is White's best piece it
looks aggressive but it's really a
defensive piece protecting what
otherwise would be a loose E4 Pawn God
C3 is such a bon move putting the pawn
on pre two different minor pieces can
capture it there's some crazy lines with
Bishop C3 Bishop A4 Bishop B5 Bishop C2
Bishop F6 Bishop D1 I feel like at the
end of it black wins a queen and black
white
doesn't takes six Tak six takes yes
logical logical yeah yeah I mean C3
pretty good move Robert but I think
black Black's Counterpoint queen that
probably outweighs White's extra Pawn
but could go either way chat I'm not
thinking this going either way I'm
thinking it's all black in this position
unless Levy has a way to successfully
defend his pawns which I don't easily
see it seems like black is having all
the fun here and I'm looking at the
clock it seems easier to be aggressive
Knight C4 for example you have to take
on C4 Rook takes back you can't move the
Knight without losing C2 or E4 this
looks terrible for white and let's not
forget about the G4 square that is a
base of operations for some of Black's
minor pieces he's kept that move in his
pocket for a rainy day I think that
rainy day has arrived skies are gray
around White's King and I think the
Knight is jumping into G4 opening up the
bishop on G7 you called it Robert it was
only a matter of time before that Bishop
would have its moment in the sun I think
it stopped raining this looks like a bko
where White's not even going to be up a
pawn like all of the queenside play is
just crushing Queen C5 is on the agenda
the C3 Knight is currently hanging
behind it the C2 Pawn is loosing Queen
F3 threatens Queen takes F7 so don't get
greedy Greg shahadi do not take that
Knight on C3 Levy is a very resilient
player he's not just going to curl up
into a ball and let Greg run circles
over him on the queen side Lev is going
to try to use his only asset which is
this Knight on G5 and I think he can use
tactics to make this interesting Knight
to B5 and he spotted it and that Knight
could even circle around to A7 and C6
great call by you great fin KN what's
going to happen if Knight A7 Rook A8 I
think Knight C6 and then Knight takes C7
and queen takes F7 was a
perpetual
okay that is a ridiculous find and Greg
when Queen B6 he gets an X usually that
marks the spot but here marks a mistake
and Knight A7 found with Knight C6 to
follow as you mentioned the F7 Pawn is
too tender boy has the landscape of the
position has changed Greg should have
thrown in the move Knight E5 in order to
secure the C6 Square the bishop is now
overloaded you can't play Bishop takes
C6 obviously because of Queen takes F7
Greg tries to get that Knight off the
board Levy could even swing his Queen to
B3 instead he goes for the trade but
still the position a lot more
double-edged than it was just a couple
of moves ago and here come the trades
liquidation helps uh White because the
queen side feels safer but also helps
black because what are you going to
Checkmate me just your knight and your
queen I don't think that's going to work
so Bishop F4 play Greg thinking here you
can see he senses that he might have
some opportunities and is black with
more activity but white is defended
everywhere and the Knight is the
trickier piece in time scrambles E5 is
Levy playing for a win here
yes you answer that just so matter of
factly very dead pan I think he is I
think he senses Greg kind of losing the
thread for the last couple of moves but
doing a great job of offering the queen
trade establishing his Queen on
D6 and it's still anybody's
game you have to watch out not a blunder
if you're a Greg Bishop C4 don't take on
D5 cuz Knight F6 check will Fork the
king and the bishop I would go Rook D1
and Rook D4 try to keep your Pawn on D5
alive if you can win D6 then it's a game
Rook C4 I think might be The Prudent
drawing move Rook C4 is a great choice
forcing the Rooks off the board and then
if you take on D6 then black will take
on D5 he finds it great stuff by Greg
and yet again I've made this point many
times he's done an excellent job in time
scrambles and he did a great job there
of avoiding Bishop takes D5 how many
times have we seen players blunder like
that it was the one trick available you
still have to be Careful by the way I
think White's going to win this game
because at some point white might have
what Happ why you King of6 King F6 was
winning you would have just sat on
Black's position and won all the pawns
back why did he allow the king out I
think even if it's not objectively
winning from a practical standpoint it's
hard to play this as as black and as
long as he doesn't blender a fork he has
everything under control But Here Comes
G4 at the right moment for White and the
thing is there are some Pawn end games
like three on three Pawn games that are
actually winning for the side with a
more active King so L going to keep
trying here Greg needs to get some more
pawns off the board and I think he's
found the ideal defensive G check play
G5 and trade off all the
pawns
absolutely even Bishop takes G4 was
working but G5 is an insta draw and now
G5 for white it's of course still a draw
but this only gives white some chances
we've seen situations where a player
gets nervous blunders the bishop
Bishop C4 there would have kept the
Knight stalemated but Greg's Greg shown
a great ability to survive more
complicated positions than this I'm just
looking at the time Levy's clock is
increasing Greg his clock is down to
about 6 seconds but the problem is for
Levy's winning chances is the only way
you blunder is if you just hang a fork
but the bishop and King have been quite
separated Bishop B1 Bishop F5 is a great
set of essentially prees but you called
it Robert Levy actually had a chance
there to put put his kick on F6 and the
position would have been objectively
winning so frustrating on the other hand
it was a great save it was a great job
by Levy to even get to the situation in
the first place and it's still a
two-point lead for Greg and Greg offers
a draw Levy accepts Greg shakes out his
hands and the next game begins and for
Levy maybe he should have tried a cheapo
remember that earlier game where you
praised Greg for playing G5 hoping to
catch Levy in a pre move I feel like
Levy should have tried to catch Greg one
there but no no matter what it's still a
two-point lead for Greg Shah we're back
to this opening who do you think should
deviate from this line well okay the
first Caro Kong game they had was a
textbook positional win for Greg Levy
made a very useful modification this
bishop F5 idea gives black a much easier
position to play with his control over
the E4 Square I think that both players
are probably decently Satisfied by this
structure but this is a huge momentum
game Robert it's likely going to be the
last game of the three-minute portion
if GRE can win it and open up his
largest lead of the match I think he's
going to be very well poised to take
this match in the bullet G4 this is a
big moment for Greg because if black
takes you UND double your pawns but you
open up the H file and The Rook on H1 is
very happy to see that pawn on H7 down
the line and I think at some point
you're going to play G4 if you're white
and and I have to ask you da is Levy
playing the match score right now or the
position yeah he might be playing I mean
the way B5 and B I think answers your
question Levy going for the win at all
costs but he's also burned his bridges
in the sense that his King is now
permanently stuck in the center
literally you've moved both of your
Rooks so you can't castle if Greg can
find a way to open up even a single
Avenue to Black's King there will be
major storm clouds gathered around
Black's King and Robert maybe I'm
missing the point here but Levy's attack
just doesn't seem scary I feel like he
doesn't have enough Firepower he doesn't
have enough peace coordination to cause
serious problems against White's King
and white is staring in both directions
not only is white prepared for what was
L was hoping to be a kingside Onslaught
that queen go to H6 at any moment to hit
that lonely H7 Pawn just get into
Black's position and so Knight E7 Queen
H6 now makes a lot of sense if you're
getting greedy but inste goes C4 I like
that too a dynamite move yeah
strategically you're giving up the D5
square but this position isn't about
squares it's about one thing and one
thing only which is Black's King Greg
tries to open the C file but Levy
responds by gathering his pawns as close
as possible to White's
King okay so now there are threats is it
going to be A3 is it going to be B3 not
always easy for the player with the
white piece to figure out which Pawn is
going to storm down towards your king
and look at Greg go just Rook to D1 so I
know C4 earned a question mark the
evaluation still in White's favor maybe
there was something more adventurous
that would have been better for black
but I think that now Queen H6 check now
you have to do it with Knight F4 Knight
H5 to follow exactly even though the
check can be blocked with Rook G7 and
maybe that's part of Levy's overall
strategy to get the king to G8 that
offers no relief a contra if White's
Knight gets to H5 that Knight can jump
into F6 with check so that King is going
from the frying pan Into the Fire and
Greg starts with Knight F4 he thinks
that preventing King G7 or Rook G7 is
the smart way to start and I don't see
an easy plan for black because d one of
the big questions if you push A3 and
white plays B3 sort of fixing the
structure on the queen side most of
those end games will be losing for black
and that's why Levy is playing this more
actively watch out for Knight B3 check
at the right moment and that could
deliver Checkmate down the a file great
tactical awareness by you Robert you
could even meet C takes D5 with Queen to
A6 now white has ways of dealing with
this threat but in some situations even
if White's King slinks away to B1 Knight
B3 could still be possible you could run
into a situation where Queen A2 is
Unstoppable even though it's not a check
and he's actually helping the queen get
to A6 bad move by Greg here I think he's
underestimating the danger that awaits
him on the queen side I think he has
play Queen D3 here there's no Knight B3
check with the Queens staring at one
another he finds that and you know what
his claim is that the pawn structure is
better for white so some of these end
games will still be a plus for him the
engine doesn't seem to think so but Greg
we can get where he's coming from
absolutely this Pawn on C5 big asset at
the same time black has the C6 Square
under control Levy keeps the Queens on
the board but this offers white more
chances on the king side remember our
old friend G4 that could strike at a
very inconvenient time for black if Lev
doesn't find a way to whip up more
tactical chances uh near White's King
Greg is eventually going to get the
engine started on the other side of the
board I think now's the perfect time to
strike with G4 I'm completely with you
there partner and I'm sure there's a
rushan expression for it that you'll
teach me but when black plays A3 white
plays B3 when black plays B3 white plays
A3 what's that
called it I Ro Rons like it's it's
untranslatable but there is literally an
expression for this exact situation
where A3 is met with B3 B3 is met with
A3 and was that another mouse slip no
but A3 B3 Knight B2 wins in exchange but
da do you remember that earlier game
where Greg lost in exchange but we still
preferred his position because it's
closed the Rooks don't have open files
no it's exactly like that position so
was this a blunder was this uh
deliberately planned it doesn't matter
it's a moot point because the knights
are absolutely stronger than the Rook
here and this queen H6 and Knight F4
Knight H5 I almost called you Greg but
the actual Greg I think is finally going
to dive into the appropriate square but
again he plays Knight F4 first but
Knight H5 this looks very dangerous for
the black king and that Knight on E2 can
slink back to C1 up to D3 that B4 Pawn
is tender so The Rook on B8 is a bit
tied down as well yeah if you want a
perfect textbook example of a minor
piece being better than the Rook look no
further than this game great practical
Try by Levy though opening up the center
and trying to develop more prospects for
his rook and there goes Greg with Queen
takes D5 yeah Queen E2 is Checkmate
Queen D6 and Knight F6 mate so you
cannot go peace grabbing here and that
means that Levy's position is falling
apart the seams 10 seconds for Levy as
he gets his Rook involved he's going to
have to play perfectly here in order to
maintain the balance 7 seconds for Levy
what do you do I don't have a move Rook
it's the it's the best move from the
engine what a move sacking The Exchange
back in order to fix his Pawn structure
and douse the Flames of White's
initiative this is
incredible that is a phenomenal move he
also gives his King some more space the
G8 Square in particular and he goes G5
all out Knight D3 now for white though
you can start trading cuz White's up
pawn it still feels like with two
seconds on the clock Queen D6 check is a
favorable trade for white Levy still
trying to
hold this is losing because not only is
white up a pawn but you if let's say
black could stop the pawn which now you
can't even do that there would have been
H4 and white would have created another
pass pawn and worst comes to worst those
pawns on A3 and B4 you called it a long
time ago those pawns become a big
liability in the end game and Greg
shahade on the strength of some amazing
positional play he takes the game and
opens up his largest lead of the match
Robert going into the bullet segment
it's what Greg has been relying on is
some of these end games look at this
this has shades of
2021 two-point advantage in the longest
time control to Greg shahadi one point
added on to Greg shahadi 8 and 1 half 5
and A2 but da we know what happened two
years back it was a Bullet Storm from
Levy Rosman and so going into the
quickest time da I'm going to pass the
mic to you buddy what do you think what
are Levy's odds at I think they're
pretty high Levy I think comparatively
speaking bullet is his strongest time
control and historically it's been
Greg's weakest but this feels like a
different Greg shahadi in 2023 it's a
faster Greg Shah a more confident one
and he has met Levy blow for blow more
so he has been the superior player in
time scrambles so Levy is going to have
to push nerves aside take some
inspiration from 2021 Robert and Greg
will have to do the
opposite yeah Greg he's been playing
great chess he's been playing well even
in time trouble so he need to make use
of that chat get involved let us know do
you think it'll be Levy or do you think
it'll be Greg moving on and also chat
please get involved become a part of our
community join the official chess.com
Community Club this is the place to be
for all info on community tournaments
giveaways contest and other events plus
connect with the community and stay up
todate on the Chess World use the
command community in chat to get in on
the action da I mean people should join
the community that way they're updated
with all of these events and more but we
are going to say bye to the community
but just for a minute because we get a
break and then return for the bullet
portion of this I am match you will not
want to miss any the action returning in
just a
[Music]
few what
four years chess kit has had lots of fun
online events but it's finally time for
us to go IRL in real life puzzle
competitions a main event and all sorts
of other fun things to do announcing the
chess kid national
festival come along you'll meet fun
Master mik there I'm going to the chess
kit Festival I'm going to the chess kit
Festival I'm going to the
[Music]
festival you guys play chess you want to
talk about it we do let's do oh yeah
where do you play chess at in Al okay
when I say chess the first word that
pops into your
mind protect my queen hakaru
intelligence strategy tactics Toby
Maguire oh my God you saw Pawn sacrifice
if you're on Tinder and you're scrolling
and someone has a chess player on their
profile is that swipe left or swipe
right swipe right is good right yeah
then yeah instant swipe right okay super
into that right I'm into it you're ready
to probably whatever the swipe is I
don't not interested you're you're not
interested in chess players I'm not
interested chess players are on Tinder
oh I get that in fact that checks out if
I as you to name one chess player in the
world can you name a chess
player yeah no no I canot anay Joy C blo
wow name another one oh casprov casprov
if you name five other world champions
in the next 15 seconds I'm going to give
you $50 carpov
spasy
Paar Carlson
and Anon Anon holy he did you get
50 bucks dude oh my God we just lost $50
whose idea was
[Music]
that
d
[Music]
hey
d
[Music]
he
d
[Music]
here's a man who needs to learn from his
own book how to win at chess by Levy
Rosman he's going to need to figure that
out ASAP da he currently Trails 8 and
half 5 and a half and it's been a great
all-around match for Greg shahad he's
demonstrated so many good skills from
opening preparation to the ability to
survive and thrive under the duress of
time pressure to positional victories to
Great tactical foresight Greg shahade
holds a three-point lead and he deserves
every one of those eight and a half
points that he has garnered but the
match is anything but over if you think
it is Robert and that means you haven't
seen a single SEC match and it means you
have not learned from History 8 and 1
half 5 and half was the score back in
2021 do the math 4 plus 4 and 1/2 8 and
1/2 3 + 2 and 1/2 5 and 1/2 the same
exact score two years ago and Levy won 8
to2 in bullet to win by the score of 13
half 10 half so da we know Levy's
capable of it he's done it before do you
think it's going to happen again I think
it very well might now 25 minutes is a
very long time in the context of bullet
but it's simultaneously a long time and
not a long time if you're Levy you
cannot afford to drop the first couple
of games in the bullet we know from
previous observations of how comebacks
tend to work in bullet that it always
starts by getting off to a good start
you win that first game you get your
feet under you and before you know it a
three-point lead can be raced instantly
so the first one or two games Robert I
think they are going to be the biggest X
Factor toward determining whether Levy
has a comeback chance you are a bullet
brawl Champion so I will take your word
for it the one thing that I personally
have noted throughout this match is that
I thought Greg would struggle more in
the time scrambles but no Greg has
actually been quite strong he's been
winning some of those scrambles so that
doesn't bode as well for Levy's chances
as you would have predicted before the
match began but speaking of before the
match predictions 92% of you said Levy
Rosman win what are you saying now get
involved chat let us know your thoughts
who do you think is going to win will it
be Greg shahadi up three points or it
will be Levy Rosman who back in 2021 was
down three to Greg and storm back to
Victory the energy in the chat has been
amazing so thank you to everybody the
energy in this match has been amazing
and we are going to get rewarded with 20
5 minutes of high octane super
entertaining bullet action 90% still
think that levie Rosman is going to take
this match we are off and very important
Robert in the early going for the
players not to over adjust one plus one
is a pretty generous time control it's
not the same as 1 plus zero you know
what is the same the opening Choice
played by both players no adjustments at
least not many yet but the bishop went
back to D2 and queen H5 so Greg is
relying on his endgame skill if he wins
the match we'll have to ask ask him
about it but this has been something
he's done time and time again but Knight
G5 we've seen this move played Time and
Time Again by Levy he ultimately ends up
taking the bishop on E6 damaging Black's
Pawn structure and procuring the bishop
pair much easier position to play for
white but we've seen the structure time
and time again and Greg has found ways
to thrive in it and he's allowing E5
we've seen this exact position maybe he
should start with Knight D7 before
playing Bishop G7 that would stop white
from having this up his sleeve but
letting goes for it Rook H1 next and
Greg is going to rely on his remaining
pieces because his triple isolated pawns
if he had decided to take on E5 would
have been miserable but I think he's
just going to get massacred in the
center Bishop F4 Greg might have been
playing a little bit too fast here
Bishop F4 seemed like a much more
effective way to hit D6 now he's allowed
D5 and we've seen this type of situation
before where Greg's Knights as passive
as they look actually control a lot of
important squares in his territory he's
also up 37 seconds on the clock and it's
essential that Knight on d8 is doing
some Heroes work because the Knight went
back to C3 if it went up to G5 it
threaten nothing as your arrows
indicated so now he takes that Bishop
off of B3 and I'm sorry whose Pawn
structure is worse Black could have had
tripled pawns now black has the
healthier Pawn structure Levy though has
the better central control he can stick
a bishop on E5 ultimately try to get the
Knight around to D4 and put pressure on
this E6 Pawn I would start by doubling
the Rooks and Rook E8 Robert this is a
major nuisance for black is always going
to be met with tactics along the E file
well that's a tail as old this time and
speaking of time is the one down 20
seconds Here Comes kn4 though Greg fell
asleep on that move he could have played
E5 he did all of that work to put his E
Pawn and now he didn't but he's playing
too quickly that's Greg's problem is
he's up plenty of time he's rushing his
decisions and he still has a chance is
an extra Pawn for white this F Pawn but
black kind of has an extra Pawn too in
the center white has these double pawns
but the engine saying that this should
be a win for white I think Greg pushed
that pawn too soon D4 was another bad
move Greg bling very sloppy here he's
over 30 seconds on the clock you have to
know when to pause in a one plus one
game you can't keep up the same Pace
yeah it's good to play fast but 18
seconds with a 1 second increment Robert
is an ocean of time for someone as
experiences Levy oh and look at Levy go
he he's trapping The Rook is B5 but now
you can just pick up D4 Rook takes D4
and there's no moves for black F5 and
Rook D5 is going to force the Rook you
could even play Rook D5 immediately if
you want to be fancy and he does
amazing amazing fine there by you and by
Levy and Greg do not resign this is now
where the meta strategy comes into play
you play these out and just waste time
off the match clock and you can waste a
great deal of time now the SEC regular
format calls for 30 minutes of bullet 25
minutes you can milk down another minute
mid and a half off the clock so you're
already going to have to play the clock
from the very first seconds and it's
mate in one either Queen A7 or queen A1
so don't move now because King A3 Queen
a1's mate King A5 Queen A7 Checkmate so
Greg is going to lose on time in this
game and it's not poor sportsmanship
it's part of the match format we've seen
it in so many sec's past and Greg he
doesn't like the look of his position he
doesn't like the starts to the bullet
but all the levy fans out there can
Rejoice absolutely a huge start I
mentioned that the first game is going
to be crucial not just for the match
score but also for the confidence level
one more win and it's a one-point game
and Levy is going to stick to his trid
and true carak on that A6 variation and
we've seen this structure so many times
this match but one big difference is
White's Pawn is on D4 rather than Fen
ketoing the dark score Bishop so this
makes it more french-like except black
is not saddled with this horrible light
score Bishop yeah the caroan as they say
it's just like a French without the
light scored Bishop why would anybody
ever play the French when you know
there's an opening where you can
actually elim elate the French Bishop I
kid of course I still like Greg's
position I think he could set his H Pawn
in motion and he's displaying some
excellent understanding of the typical
plans in this position I think the way
you put put it just there Greg has shown
exceptional understanding all throughout
today's match and Levy he's been
tactically alert he's been finding some
great opportunities when they arise but
Knight F5 I would take that thing black
has to take with the G pawn and now it's
tough to move because you move the dark
score Bishop I get Queen G7 look at Greg
shifting Focus to the queen side and
he's not letting Levy breathe but H6 I
thought Queen G7 there would have
infiltrated and picked up the H7 Punt
and again I think Greg is trying to keep
up on the clock but he's ending up
missing some of these big chances how
does levy defend against Queen G7 though
the threat was stronger than the
execution da Queen G7 was strong but
making Levy think about Queen g7's even
stronger you might have to drop back to
f8 with a bishop but another big problem
is Knight to H5 as Levy Falls to 20
seconds on the clock Greg has to win
this game this is a huge chance Knight
H5 is on the board Robert Bishop G5 and
Knight G7 you could get checkmated here
that looks great and Rook G8 was
probably necessary Bishop E7 allowing
his King to run to d8 but Knight G7
check the King has to go over to d8 and
then maybe some kind of B3 at the right
moment whoa what is that what is and
he's given up the H6 Pawn way too fancy
for Greg what was the point of that move
you don't need another Pawn on the sixth
rank if anything you're just creating
more weaknesses
so6 Queen D6 Knight takes F6 swap
Knights and queen takes A6 now at least
there's Chaos on the board has black
moved the Rook can you Castle still for
black amazingly I think you can you
haven't moved the king you haven't moved
the rook and that becomes very important
if white picks up A6 he goes for Queen
G7 I don't like that choice either this
simplifies Black's task F6 and King F7
and Levy is now firmly in the drive seat
again yeah Greg plays too quickly at
some big moments here Knight E4 kicks
The Rook off the G file this is going to
be a win for Levy once again oh watch
out for Knight D5 and King F6 almost got
checkmated still some work to do if he
can get this G7 Pawn I think he wins the
game and the good news for Greg is his
clock uh oh now the E6
oh Knight H5 back can you take that pawn
I think you should okay it goes D4 he's
setting his Pawns in motion the King
goes back to E6 F4 becomes an idea so F4
still is an idea that white is counting
on G4 excellent source of counterplay
for Greg Levy pushes C3 The Rook
infiltrates d8 it's still very much a
game and wait C2 Rook C8 Rook C7 or
something like that what's the move here
oh my gosh Rook C7 covers the check and
Levy's going to
promote or is he he's just losing yeah
he's going to take the Rook on G5 as
well and the pawn on G7 is going to fall
that's going to Signal the end of the
game and if the the first game was a
case of playing too quickly as he
blunders The Rook on G7 which wasn't
captured it's just sitting there on G7
Rook
F3 I don't know exactly what's happening
here but it looks like black is just
mopping up at the moment but what were
you going to say da yeah no if the first
game was a case of Greg just playing too
quickly the second game was even more
frustrating it wasn't that Greg played
Bishop F6 too quickly he did everything
to win the game and then panicked I
don't know got too fancy got ahead of
himself he's going to lose the second
game in a row and this is starting to
resemble 2021 again you know when you
have a bad track record and you just
start thinking the back of your head oh
it's going to happen again oh no it's
happening maybe he is psychologically in
a tough spot even though he still leads
by one point this right now is a game
that Greg can't just throw away that's
part of the issue for him is he's
getting quite nice positions and then
he's not finding the way to deliver uh
another improving move so Levy going
back to his TR and true opening Knight
to F4 it's looking good for white once
again and once again Levy immediately
grabbing the bishop on E6 we're going to
get this structure except the Queens are
on the board which affords black certain
chances on the king side Greg has to
deploy his Bishop e efficiently here but
you've also got to watch out for Knight
B5 related threats not immediately of
course that blunder
C2 well he goes A6 so he never has to
worry about it the Knight guts gets up
to C4 so dark Square control for for
black I love Rook D4 bring another piece
into the attack but where is the attack
will we see another E5 from Levy he's
shown a predilection for this move in
almost any position here he's going
directly for the attack but Knight D7
now becomes a very Natural Choice I
don't want a rook to B6 to happen I
don't want to worry about my dark Square
so Knight D7 in the very near future and
by near future I mean absolutely
necessary when Greg just played
it yeah Knight D7 defending the B6
Square man Greg has shown a really nice
ability to stay afloat in the structure
it always looks really bad E5 E5 would
have been a piece o and that's cuz the
Knight on A4 on the rim was dim and
could have been one but the Knight goes
back to C3 this still looks Pleasant for
black I don't see the big issue and
they're about even on time so both
players are doing well indeed A3
creating a stronghold on B4 Levy dodging
a major bullet there but it still feels
like Greg is starting to accumulate his
pieces on the said that Knight on C3
white has to keep a Hawkeye on that
night because of the possibility of Rook
take C3 once the Knight moves away from
C5 and it is a one-point match apologies
to everybody it's not a three-point
spread at the moment so if Levy can win
this game the match is tied for the
first time in a long while instead of
taking this Pawn on H7 as Rook D4 wants
to protect the king with the Rook to B4
aggressive and defensive move at the
same time King A8 Greg tucking his King
away the H7 Pawn is has been hanging for
what feels like an eternity and Levy is
not touching it he's playing more
conservatively making sure that C2 is
protected big chance for Greg here he
keeps improving his position the
knight's getting to C4 and Lev is
getting into trouble uhoh here comes the
Knight here comes the attack and where
to next Knight back to B6 where is that
Knight going there's also this idea of
A5 and B4 it's going right back to C4 is
there a tactic here no I would play A5
and keep White's Knight confined
but I like the way Levy's been using his
Rook he went Rook up to D4 back to D3
over to C3 he's swapping spe watch out
for it Knight takes B2 or Knight takes
A3 that is something that white really
needs to keep an eye on Greg repeating
once and he goes for it and given the
time situation and given how powerful
his Knight is I think that's a great
decision okay the Knight goes over to
that KN was blund hanging it was
literally just hanging there and he's
not going to give him a second chance
he's moving too quickly at many stages
of these games and here Queen of3 watch
out for E5 watch out for the E6 Pawn
hanging what do you do here I think you
play E5 yourself instead he's allowed
Rook D3 oh my gosh not an easy move of
spot with just three seconds on the
clock and now we see coming off White's
better B4 B4 is going to win the E5 Pawn
I really like the Knight coming to D6 B4
will be met by Knight C4 check so this
was oh but he blundered the H Pawn Now
Greg plays like he has 1 second on his
clock he's got 15 seconds and he's
losing
oh my gosh he's giving these games away
for no reason yeah he's moving way too
quickly in every game that we've seen
here he has perfectly good positions
he's leading on the clock and that he's
the one who's speeding up and it hurts
him and all credit to Levy he kept his
composure and time pressure but that
night on C3 it was literally hanging and
Greg had 20 seconds he was trying to
flag Levy and Levy is way too experienc
of a bullet player to just flag on his
own and Greg you can sense the
frustration but Robert he is doing this
to himself yeah he has no one to blame
except himself and Levy Rosman and Levy
shout out to him he could have let his
emotions get the best of him instead he
enters the bullet down three and down
three no longer it's about to be a tied
match there it is it is officially 8 and
half 8 and a half D it what does Greg do
now well the big thing right now isn't
the match score the fact that it's tied
yes it's very pleasant but can Greg
handle his nerves can he push away what
just happened and can he make an inm
match adjustment can he have the meta
awareness to say yeah here's what I'm
doing wrong I need to slow down in
critical moments I like what he's gotten
out of the opening here in the early
going a weird weird Choice by Levy to
play the Rubenstein French and what are
we going to get here I'm not sure why he
chose the French look at this position
for white I me you have to watch out for
black at some point D5 will be an idea
uh but Levy must be comfortable as he's
moving quickly every single turn Knight
C5 now is something you have to look out
for Knight C5 is ultra
unpleasant uhoh uhoh this looks really
bad there's going to be a sack on E6 and
Black's King really has nowhere to go
you might have to go kingside that might
be the Lesser evil Robert but the Knight
is going to drop into D4 the queen has a
direct path to the king side and the
Knight on B4 is also very
loose yes in fact if you Castle King
side watch out for queen 4 check ideas
whoa King went to took on d8 and Greg
once again moved very quickly there it
makes a lot of sense does he have a take
on E6 Queen the bishop works with the
bishop I think because you can't touch
the Knight due to the fork and he spots
it but it's not over yet Rook E8 and
Rook D1 we've got total pandemonium I
play Queen D2 here oh excellent move
maybe Queen D6 but the bishop takes F7
oh wow and there's a mate on E8 at the
end and that's what you oh Bishop def
what a move from Levy incredible move by
Levy covering the defile and leading to
a bunch of Trades and Levy actually
might emerge relatively unscathed he'll
be a pawn down after Bishop F7 though
okay so Bishop takes F7 threatens Queen
E8 mate whoa he missed it he plays
Bishop
E4 threatening C3 though okay that does
cover the diagonal your as your B3 now
is force as Queen takes A2 is a pretty
big threat even A3 was possible there
but B3 is the human move H7 is also
hanging and that's actually a huge Pawn
because it gives him the passer but look
at white king suddenly squares suddenly
there are
threats and the King needs to escape the
defile if you are Levy he goes to the
queen side the engine doesn't seem to
love it but Queen D4 now
B4 and queen takes F2 is an idea at some
point oh my gosh Queen A5 he's going to
get
mated go Queen D4 instead the engine not
impressed where there has to be
something here Lev is just mopping up
the pawns he's taking on A2 he's going
to drop back to C3 and he might just
take on H4 and say I'm a pawn up now he
is a pawn ahead Queen E1 saving the
first rank now the king can go back to
B2 it safely does G2 can be captured
Queen E8 check becomes an idea Bishop
takes A6 is also loose no Bishop E4
because that square is controlled by
Black's Knight oh GRE TR a second Queen
probably ah Queen C6 and queen takes F7
the game continues it absolutely does
this is a three res game but Levy keeps
his composure and he's going to cover
all the checks Queen B7 is mate so do
not allow that four seconds for Levy
Queen takes F6 Here Comes Greg uh oh yep
Greg on the offensive where is the Black
Knight going he under attack now Queen
d8 is almost Checkmate the King has to
go up to B5 how do you save this King B1
no Perpetual the king hides on A2 Queen
B7 is going to hurt Queen A7 Queen D7
don't blender your
queen and Greg plays on he takes the F7
Pawn he wants to hunt the black king but
why could just as easily get checkmated
and he does Greg shahadi plays on he was
playing for a win but he played for a
loss and Levy he showed composure under
the stress of the moment and he takes
the first lead in a long time and Greg
is now officially on the ropes he's
facing what feels like his first deficit
of the match it actually might be Levy
Rosman with Knight D1 at the end setting
up that mating net against White's King
you can understand why Greg played on it
looked like Black's King was in a was
caught in a net but Levy finding so many
only moves there dodging so many bullets
and now Greg actually needs to win but
now we have to say this opening from
Levy doesn't look particularly
impressive to my eyes not that you need
an opening Advantage but black is
clearly doing quite nicely so I haven't
liked Levy's opening switching to the
French and now playing uh E4 from the
white side and A3 on move two look at
this Knight C7 check looks like that
Knight has a Death Wish Levy protecting
with Bishop F4 he's threatening rook ad1
and then Knight A8 Knight B6 could be an
idea okay so Rook
D1 what is Black's followup because
you're right that if you swap Rooks the
Knight does have some Escape squares
this looks questionable and look at
Levy's clock there is this insane idea
to play Rook D6 in order to slice off
the connection between the Knight and
the Rook now I think you just go E6 and
Bishop D6 and win the
game um you know how we were saying we
didn't like the opening I think Levy
also doesn't like the opening choice
that he just made he's got to try C5 you
have to stop Bishop D6 at all costs now
Bishop D6 is 01 you're just going to
drop this Knight it's a full piece and
Greg paused at the right moment finds
Bishop D6 and look at Levy's face he's
like what was I thinking
and it wasn't just the second move it
was E4 C5 A3 called the mangerini
variation Levy still trying look at that
move B4 so tricky and I love that Greg
is pausing in critical moments he's done
a much better job of it this particular
game as he's going to hide on D7 with
his King and how do you keep that Knight
because Bishop to E5 Rook E4 oh it takes
on C4 stealing a pawn threatening Rook
takes C7 anyway the king Knight D5 saf
ah Knight D5 if King C8 there's Knight
A8 Knight A8
oh my God what an idea and it's not over
yet the king is still a little bit Airy
yeah Rook takes C7 would Me by Pawn A7
and white would have won so look at this
connecting The Rook into the game but
Rook the check is an idea and it could
be made if a piece lands on D7 if the
wrong piece lands on D7 I should say
Greg says I want nothing to do with the
queen side he gets this King back to the
center but he's not converting this very
confidently I think Levy still got
practical chances Levy has under 5
seconds so that's not good for him but
take on D5 take on G7 there good chances
to hold that G7 was just given away by
Greg Levy doesn't take it and now F6 and
E5 could be devastating oh but E6 BS
yeah that was a big mistake from Greg
yes oh what is he doing and he might
lose this he could lose this no Way's
choking he's choking this away Rook A1
Rook
C1 that threatens Checkmate but he kicks
the N Out first I like that now Rook A1
then he's not doing it and Levy playing
a little bit too passively here
objectively this position is probably
drawn practically black is still better
because of the M threats on the first
Rank and that's a m threat if I've ever
seen one Rook H1 check if you have a
knight H2 look at the way that Lev's
guarding knight2
N1 oh my gosh that could be a Checkmate
in the near future that was G Knight G4
you couldn't take it Knight G4 was
crushing now Lev is going after the H
Pawn Knight G Knight G4 again is there
Rook A3
the king escapes oh my gosh and it's
still winning for black king E6 who
who's getting checkmated it might be
black H Rook
f8 oh my gosh Rook E7 you can't escape
the checks oh wi the bishop King oh King
D6 you check on D2 oh and he still keeps
it
going oh my goodness what a match we
have seen and it looks like Greg he's
coming out on top all he needs to do is
keep his Rooks connected and push the
passer I can't believe what we're seeing
Levy going for some sort of stalemate he
wants this to come down to the wire
there's less than four minutes left in
the match and now both players need to
be aware of the match clock because Greg
he is going I think it's not too ear say
he's about to convert this I hope so
Blend or anything no Rosen trap no pre
moves just win the game
man that's a good idea by the way Rook
H6 check to make sure that there are no
stalemates God Greg is taking his sweet
time just go Rook G8 queit F6 man just
made him
already all right so we have 3 minutes
20 seconds remaining it is 9 and a half
9 and half Greg he breathes for the
first time in five games and now there
might just be one game remaining to D
this is what we noted the players need
to be aware of the batch if you're dead
lost resign to get that last game in we
have seen so many matches lost because
of that lack of awareness now from time
to time you just need to really quickly
glance at the match clock and judge
whether your position is worth
continuing Levy repeating the Rubenstein
French he got a really bad position the
first time he played it this time Robert
he is controlling the D5 square and I
think he's a lot more solid out of the
opening than in the previous Rubenstein
game yeah it's much more normal as
normal as Rubenstein French gets and
here you swap Bishops white will then
say I have a better Pawn structure black
will say give me the D5 and F5 squares
my Rook on G8 it's not a bad piece so I
think that black isn't doing badly but I
would definitely prefer White and the
Queen on A4 is a liability you have to
be very careful not to blund Rook A3
Queen D7 though oh you're lucky that he
doesn't lose a queen A6 check and he
goes Queen A6 he wants like C4 and
Bishop F4 but isn't going to work out it
looks like black is on the ropes but
white actually could be on the ropes
that Rook on A3 could get under the line
of fire of the of the bishop and he
gives up two pieces for Rook interesting
decision is there D6 or is that asking
for too much no he just decides to take
the piece right away now E5 E4 I think
practically Robert because of Black's
advantage in the center I really like
black here I think Levy has a big
Advantage but Greg can play Queen on the
L A Piece he hung a piece Queen takes F3
it's over you got to resign yes you he
does have a minute 30 plus so he as long
as he's aware of the match clock he can
resign in a little little bit but he
should not play this much longer Queen
takes F2 Queen takes D2 is the big
threat Levy fully composed finding Queen
D7
there and I'm keeping an eye on the
match clock cuz this could easily drag
on for a minute and if Levy senses that
Greg has lost track of the match clock
he actually could stall this out
deliberately I would do that if I were
Levy just start spending time right now
and queen D5 good move trying to swap
the Queens off you have an extra Rook
for a bishop you have some pass Pawns
but I mean this is getting close only
one minute remains Greg better have an
eye on the time yeah as an experienced I
am not a GMC player Greg has to be aware
of the clock he can compose himself it
doesn't matter if you resign now or with
10 seconds left on the match clock he
resigns now and thankfully we're in for
another game it's a must-win for Greg
shahade with the black pieces and you
could see Greg look at the match clock
that's what he was doing he's been on
Focus mode he didn't even know he was
leading by three points that's what we
were told the staff working hard behind
the scenes and here we have the trpovski
Sicilian whatever you want to call it
it's been a fun day of this opening
D Greg is feeling happy about the
repetition of opening I think he's okay
with it I think he's shown better
maneuverability in these positions than
Levy there's no question that white is
much better objectively but Greg knows
where the pieces belong he's going to
deploy his bishop and he's got the
spicier play against whites King so for
a bullet opening this is not bad at all
and he's already doing great Queen A5
this has worked out perfectly for Greg
he has the Knight on D7 the bishop on G7
none of this E5 business and Levy's move
right now isn't so easy to play A7 well
defended and so for Levy he goes Queen
D2 trying to swap Queens when you're
ahead and your opponent needs to win
telling them get into the end game come
on beat me there probably a good thing
to do great mature decision by Levy I'm
not sure that the queen trade can be
successfully avoided Greg does avoid it
and you can understand where he's coming
from but Levy could even move his Queen
back to F2 using the fact that he can
draw as a weapon instead he uses the
bishop as a weapon and Greg might have
to make a very awkward move contorting
himself to keep the E6 Pawn protected
and he plays it and he kind of is like
all right if I have to I have to but
look at Levy going Queen F2 and queen D2
back now you might try to repeat moves
Greg of course will not allow a draw
Greg's fighting two enemies he has to go
back to d8 because Robert Queen A4 would
have gotten the queen trapped and yeah
you have to go for B6 I would have
played A6 but understandably GRE doesn't
want to weaken the dark squares and
still very much a three res game oh for
sure the Rook on C8 is well positioned
Rook D2 a nice defensive move but here
come black speci as is his time to shine
Knight C4 swap off that Bishop for the
Knight get your Rook on C4 he starts
with queen D7 hitting that Knight
where's that Knight going to I wouldn't
go anywhere I would have gone Queen E2
and try to keep your light squ Bishop
intact now the bishop is gone finally
green start to unwind his position get
the Knight over to G6 get the Rook to C8
bring your pieces to the queen side
ASAP and he goes Queen C8 Knight G6 or
Knight D7 well not Knight D7 that hangs
the E6 Pawn now Knight D7 is more
possible watch out for sacrifices Bishop
takes B6 becomes an idea it doesn't work
yet because the queen can block on B7
but he goes for it take on
b76 and Greg's probably like wait does
this actually work and Levy was slow to
play Queen takes B6 Rook takes D6 does
that lead to anything oh what a great
find by you Levy misses it Rook C5 would
pin the Knight and now Levy's on the
ropes Knight E5 is coming in Robert the
Knight is coming in to
C4 have overtime this looks over Knight
C4 is going to hurt the B2 Pawn the
queen The Rook all threatened and Levy
his Queen is also on the verge being
Knight C6 Knight C6 doesn't quite trap
the queen Knight C4 is even better B2
Falls B2 Falls takes B2 and then take on
A4 and then take on B5 takes takes takes
it's and then takes white king Knight
takes A4 spotted he's a couple moves
away from forcing overtime and now you
can take on C4
is loose and it's over after takes B5
Levy can't even get the queen back and
he lets his flag run out and Greg win's
on demand and it is 10 and a half 10 and
a half Greg shahadi he evens it up he
needed that Victory he had no choice and
with his back against the wall Greg wins
sips some water and says let's go to
overtime they are not going to get a
break down here that was badass from
both players for Levy to come back from
three points down they've got only a
couple of moments to compose himself all
smiles and thumbs up from Greg shahadi
the momentum is now on his side and I
think we've earned ourselves in overtime
so of the players this has been
amazing and we see 10 and 1 12 points
for each player five points for Levy
just two for Greg in the bullet Levy's
been exceptional and I think that we
have liftoff the games are beginning we
have a 4 game mini match of taking place
starting right now so let's go to the
games because the players they're not
stopping for anyone they are not the
game is underway let's take you to the
game it's another Rubenstein French Levy
repeating the choice in his bullet games
going from the carocon to the Rubenstein
French feeling comfortable in the pawn
structure and I can see why Robert he's
got that g file that he can operate on
but that's why Greg put that Bishop on
G3 saying please take me I'll gladly
have a pawn in your rook's path Queen E4
check a nice move going after the H7
Pawn is is he going to be greedy
absolutely he's feeling lucky and he
goes right see this is smart if he can
bring that Queen back to E4 centralize
try to squap Queens why not steal a pawn
now there's no more danger against this
King I would grab that Queen off the
board but you don't actually have to
rush the queen trade isn't going
anywhere and queen takes C6 could
actually help Black's King get closer to
the center Greg has everything that he
might want out of the opening and he
went Rook D1 he might play D5 let's
trade Queens on even better terms for
white actually D5 threatens to win
material so that's why the Knight goes
back to E7 and do you trade now da or do
you still leave the queen on C6 yeah he
doesn't want to kick the can down the
road any further but he's quote unquote
only up a pawn but that's a passed Pawn
on H2 that's a massive asset in any
endgame where the pieces simplify Levy
has to keep as many pieces on the board
as possible try to get some counterplay
going on the king side just because the
Queens are off the board doesn't mean
that Greg is fully out of the woods on
the king side and Greg missed this move
thinking Knight takes D6 that Levy would
have to take the Knight no Levy will
take the bishop but that's good news for
Greg oh he get Bishop H4 instead I
didn't like that decision but his Bishop
can find safety on F6 man he's asking
for trouble if Levy had a pawn already
on F6 that Bishop would have gotten
trapped and now Knight F3 check and Greg
has lost control of the game and look at
Greg in time Trouble In For the First
Time C takes D6 and Knight F3 to follow
C takes D6 hits the bishop he gives a
check
first and that Knight can survive that
Knight wears a going though to F5 maybe
to triple black pawns and then pick up
the E1 but what a difficult move that is
6 seconds for Greg and instead he just
takes Knight takes the pawn how could
you blame for this I think white is
better here the entrance is even but
it's a bishop and two pawns for Rook
Levy switched up the move order he could
have been a full piece up instead it's
an exchange for several pawns Greg
keeping the king confined on D5 and the
position finally stabilizes but I agree
Robert I think White's position much
easier to play if you set your kingside
Pawns in motion oh and there's going to
be D5 check just shattering Black's Pawn
structure and H4 then Pawn to G3 I mean
the Rooks do not have open files if you
can get your Pawn to H6 you are tying
down Black's Rooks completely Greg
positioning his pawns on perfect squares
they're defending each other they're
giving the bishop an outpost and he's
got every chot shot at converting this
no this is an impossible position to
play as black you're shuffling around
hoping to survive long enough but white
improving move by move while G4 now
comes to mind for white let's just get
that King active in the end game at the
same time Robert Greg is 4 seconds will
he have the guts to go for it no he
takes the repetition and he's m i see
your eyes got wide uh my eyes got wide
his eyes were wider he's like what no
why but he didn't have time to calculate
Levy doing better on the clock in that
first of four tiebreak games it feels
like Greg has been less confident in
time scrambles that's the way that
bullet Works he played so well in the 5
and three minute portions but just not
feeling it in that position the first
game ends in a draw feels like the first
draw we've had all match it isn't but
it's the first draw we've had in a while
it's not the first chowski that we've
had in a
while yeah the players they're back to
the drawing board and they're going for
this line once again we are going to
need a new opening and that probably
will take place in tomorrow's other
semi-final match but this worked out for
Greg the last time he had a on demand
win with the black pieces because he
successfully was able to deploy his
bishop and get his Knight back to D7
first of all great pun back to the
drawing board I see what you did there
but again the frustrating thing for Levy
he keeps putting pressure on E6 but it's
just not enough to compromise Black's
position Greg always seems to find a way
to get his Knights exactly where they
need to go Robert Knight C5 Bishop A2
you're looking at Knight A4 tactics the
C2 Pawn is going to hang in a lot of
these lines and so the Knight goes up to
B5 the queen can no longer go to A5
that's out of the question Queen C5
seems to be the only option and Greg has
shown that he loves himself a good end
game this end game looks pretty good for
black as cramped as Black's position is
his pieces are starting to unfurl the
pawn on G5 is so nicely placed to
completely limit the influence of
White's Pawn chain Greg continues to
expand on the king side and I like his
position once again he plays G4 speaking
of expansion you can't take that pawn G4
you'll lose E4 then G4 and G2 to follow
so there will likely be a swap on F3
that means that black has fewer pawns
remaining and when you have Knights and
your opponent has a bishop compared to
one of those Knights you don't
necessarily want Pawns on both sides of
the boards because Bishops are longrange
pieces very well said we might get a
rook trade here I think both players are
fine with that the pawn slides forward
to E5 keeping that Knight on white side
of the board and B4 there was winning a
piece o that was missed by both players
now if we take on F6 we get two Bishops
versus two knights but those Knights are
dancing and that Rook on C8 will likely
go to h8 the F3 Pawn is loose and that's
why it was defended Black's entire Army
is dancing I agree Rook H great whole
board awareness by Greg missed a chance
there to win a minor piece instead he
tries to force the knights back but they
keep going forward uhoh and that Knight
it's in to E2 doesn't have a really big
threat at least not yet but it can just
pop back to F4 as you're highlighting
and that Bishop on A2 was staring Into
Thin Air it's not doing much of anything
black is chiseling and maneuvering and
dancing and jumping and shifting but
white is breaking through on the queen
side and suddenly Robert suddenly white
is threatening to play B4 and pick up
the A6 SP but I like that move Knight H5
because even though white gains a pawn
black gains activity Bishop H4 kick that
Rook out of there the H for the TR oh I
missed that I completely missed that
that was great awareness by Levy and now
with the Rooks off the board he should
be able to convert his extra Pawn but
it's far far from over Black Knights
continue to jump around the board and
I'm just looking at the a pawn a dark
squore Bishop if that's what white is
left with it might be hard to win and oh
look at that sad night it's placed in
the corner to stop the Pawn's progress
but there are two of them not just the a
pawn if black had a light squ Bishop if
that Bishop shifted over to C6 there
would be a chance to build a blockade as
it stands if white can push the B Pawn
first I think that levie is going to
break down Black's blockade momentarily
oh he has it's it's done just you can
start pushing your pawns the king into
help this is very very very good
technique just bring the king up and
then push the pawns black can try to
give up the Knight for the pawn but
White's got too many pawns remaining the
only way that black white drops this oh
wait I feel like he's making this a
little bit difficult for himself but he
I guess he has it all under control
sorry about that no I mean still it's
not easy but King B5 and where do you
get the bishop I think you get it back
to D5 and you just can't lose a move as
black either that's the problem careful
careful don't go Bishop B6
D7 Knight C4
oh chance here oh
D5 too many pawns nah wow
Rosman and again Greg has his back
against the wall Robert this is game
three of four which means Greg can
afford to draw it but if he loses then
he loses the match it will be over if
Levy can win this game so Greg he can
take a risk but it has to be measured
and we're getting this French once again
the Rubenstein variation I think Greg's
been happy with the positions he's
received after all he stole the H7 pawn
and was much better in the previous game
I wish Greg would take a little bit more
time in the the opening his decision to
bring the bishop out to E3 is pretty
lame because he covers up his own e file
and he allows Levy to Castle Queen side
we've had this structure time and time
again it's a slight Advantage for white
objectively but Levy feels that his
position is pretty easy to play and I
think he's right and if F5 I'm playing
E4 I'm trying to open the position up
because the black king wouldn't feel
truly safe now E4 for sure but he goes
Knight F3 first he doesn't want to swap
too many pieces and Levy covering the E5
Square very alert again Greg is okay
with a draw that would take it to the
final game of the tiebreaker but at this
point I think he's got to try to squeeze
out more he's clearly better at this
point yeah and Levy has played great end
games when he's had the wh sided
positions just like this so Levy showing
that he has a good understanding here
Queen goes to D5 there might be a check
at some point oh trading pieces very
conservative approach by Greg now he's
still better in the end game because
black is saddled with these weaknesses
on the king side but you know what they
say end games are always drawn and Rook
G5 was such a heads up move by Levy and
he strikes at White
Center but look at Greg striking at the
weaknesses in the king side Rook F6
coming soon and White's Pawn structure
is just healthier absolutely Rook H4
could strike at the wrong moment you
could even start with Rook F4 and then
play Rook H4 he does it in the other
order and he's just going to keep
shuffling between F4 and H4 and
compromise the activity of Black's Rooks
but lby brought his King and it exactly
the right time it's a position where
there could all three results could be
possible because white is essentially up
a Pawn on the queen side black is up a
pawn in the center and things are very
messy here and he play G4 but he's got
connected passers to
Levy okay this is looking dangerous but
white can go H6 now and after F3 I feel
like you're overextending your pawns
you're absolutely right white has to get
that King up at the right moment King D3
King E4 might be the Saving Grace but
Greg is forgetting about his King King
D3 is his last chance I think it's now
or never because after a rook takes H6
it's just going to be Levy's game for
the taking he goes Rook H5 but Rook
takes H6 that doesn't do anything he
plays right into Black's hands and this
is now officially winning for Levy once
he plays E4 the pawns are going to be an
Unstoppable Avalanche so he needs to
keep the Rooks on give up the H3 Point
go Rook H5 to G5 and then bring your
Rook to G8 and start hoping that he'll
have enough checks only chance to
somehow go after the king get Levy to
blunder a pawn and he does it but he's
got 10 seconds this is looking really
Grim oh but he goes back F5 Rook G6
check just start checking this king king
Rook back Rook D2 no uhoh yeah this
looks really good but E4 there's always
King D2 so the white king could be on E3
right now I think we'd be talking about
a different result here but now the
black king is too quick Levy needs a
couple more accurate moves though if he
play Rook H2 why would have taken and
stuck a king on F2 Rook H1 is so
accurate by Levy and this game is over
over and that means this match is over
and Levy Rosman is our first imcc
finalist of 2023 history does repeat
itself Levy beats Greg comes back in
bullet and this time he takes him down
in extra time Jubilation on the face of
Levy Rosman but I think it's almost more
relief than Jubilation when something so
stressful happens and you live through
all of that you're almost more relieved
that it's over and of course elated that
the match went your way this was amazing
great performance under pressure by both
of these players a heartbreak for Greg
shahade who won on demand to force the
tiebreaker but such a good job by Levy
to move past it and take the
tiebreaker the book wrote itself final
score locked in 13 to Levy 11 to Greg
Gotham is safe for tonight Greg shahadi
always a joker but unfortunately he does
not get the last laugh so da I feel like
Levy he really earned that match in the
bullet but Greg a lot of things were
going his way and he let it slip once
again and it's not exactly a repeat of
2021 when there was a much bigger
disaster for Greg this time he loses the
first three games of the bullet Robert
he manages to adjust and force the
overtime but it still seemed to me that
he over adjusted by and large he played
too quickly Levy paused at the right
moments he had some very astute opening
choices and Levy's endgame play toward
the end of the match was nothing short
of amazing he played fantastic chess did
Levy Rosman we're going to bring both
players on for an interview so chat
please ask your questions we may feature
your questions and ask the players but
after this quick break we'll bring Levy
Rosen AKA Gotham chess and Greg chiadi
on and we'll hear their thoughts after
what was a fantastic match be right back
everybody
[Music]
what
jacket
[Music]
sh
for
[Music]
check
Peter check where's check oh sorry
I didn't hear you say
[Music]
anything yep thanks
I thought badana played extremely well
very very solidly didn't make M didn't
make mistakes and made good positional
moves all the time the last time I was
wiped out by a woman was by Nona gaing
Dash in
1966 she beat
me she beat you two two
wins nice out I'm
retiring
[Music]
uh
mus
[Music]
and we are back with both players Greg
sorry the match didn't go your way but
Levy congratulations and Levy going to
start with you how did you come back
once again after the year 2021 the
history repeat
itself yeah I
um I don't know man I'm so tired
I I I thought it was uh the same exact
thing right as in 2021 where it was down
three going into bullet except Greg
reminded me on break that he actually
won the first bullet game two years ago
um I don't know I I I really when
there's one minute on the clock I don't
have time to build up a giant wave of
anxiety uh so I just have to move uh and
I guess you know I'm I think I'm 2,800
bullet 2900 bullet so I was able to kind
of hold it together but um yeah this
uh this doesn't this do not feel very
good uh Greg uh I'm sorry the match
should go your way you played amazing uh
there were so many good moments uh can
you talk us through how you felt in the
first two segments and what you think uh
was the missing ingredient when you got
into the book
bullet uh one more win I just need to
win one more game going bullet I kind of
calculated if I win three games out of
this 25 minutes I'm going to win the
match and I I just couldn't quite Do It
um I knew it would be really tough I
know he's very good at bullet I know
three points is not a very safe lead for
me there um but I thought I had a chance
you know I can win a game sometimes but
just couldn't win quite enough
I just have to be better at bullet and
he has to be you and Greg would talk
oops sorry about that Greg uh Levy you
and Greg were talking before we joined
back on the show about that Rook takes
E4 game and your face was in disbelief
when you hung a KN in the center there
how did you um force yourself to come
back from that moment because it could
have been a turning point of the
match I think it was a major turning
point in the match I mean if you guys
could see my message history on my phone
uh on the breaks to my friends and
family I mean you would probably like
send a a wellness check on me because
going into today's match like I once
again just like in the uh qualifiers I
um I was like I'm not going to prepare
much because every time I prepare for
hours I get you know overly stressed uh
and anxious about what's going to happen
so I showed up first game and and I I
basically decided before the match I'm
going to play these couple of of
openings uh and if Greg lets me get to
those positions I'm going to be very
happy and I'm just going to have to
convert so I was obviously very happy
that the match started the way it did
with that first win um but I wasn't able
to to hold it together with black and
those games were you know very 5050 but
uh once I hung rookie4 I once again
thought I was going to lose the match uh
and then once I went down uh two or
three I thought like there's no way I'm
winning in bullet um but then my friend
uh the legendary International Master Al
sski sent me a message and said I'm
betting all my channel points on you to
win this match so I think that's what
motivated me you know because there's
nothing more valuable in life guys than
um twitch Channel points so credit to
him he texted me and words have never
been
spoken oh well then he's a double
agent playing all the sides uh Greg you
were incredibly sharp throughout the
match tactically for particularly for
adult improvers who don't have as much
time to train regularly what do you do
to stay informed tactically and do you
think it's possible uh to keep sharp and
keep up your Blitz level without playing
actively over the board and without
studying
regularly so basically do nothing and
then get better is that is that what
you're
saying
um you know I'm really this is not quite
answering your question but I'm I'm
pretty happy with how this match went
because the last two years I have not
been focusing much on chess
um you know and I I don't know I keep my
mind sharp with other things like I've
been learning trivia I've been doing
crosswords I don't know if that helps my
tactics
um but you know I
I I don't know what to tell you some
point I guess I'm supposed to get worse
at stuff but I'm happy with how did
actually did did better this year
because I made the tie break I won two
bullet games and I don't
know this is I did a terrible job of
answering your question but I think you
just got to stay sharp got to stay sharp
all the time and play always like find
time to play a little bit oh and one
thing I did a few years ago is I came up
with a very solid opening
repertoire that I felt like I could play
Forever for the most part and and the
idea is that if I do come back and play
in games I can just go back to this kind
of like trusty thing instead of like
spending a lot of time learning new
openings and stuff like
that that's all I
got well Levy you're known to teach
everyone out there how to improve HS uh
question for you from the chat from DJ
Connell is did writing a book improve
your game this
year no I think the ceiling of the book
is uh roughly 1,00 I mean I certainly
played like couple moves today like a
1200 so I
maybe uh I don't know maybe Greg uh has
an early copy or something and he was
like training some of the stuff in there
and that's why you know he was much sure
I don't know I um I'm I'm just trying to
improve as a presenter as a teacher uh
as uh and and and just focusing on
making chess um as big as possible
naturally I have a
uh direct incentive is that in that like
da as well with our YouTube channels and
so on but um that's really what I'm
doing mostly uh I don't know every every
time I have a serious match uh it's
another kind of moment for me to either
grow I think as a uh as a person uh or
stay the same or maybe get worse so I
thought today was very similar to my
match last year with Eric where
somewhere halfway through I just like
that's it I mean I I I just completely
give up on
myself um and it it it didn't it it
luckily didn't happen uh cuz I was very
much on the edge like it very much
probably came down to like one or two
bullet games and luckily I started well
um but that's sort of how I feel but the
question was if the book has improved my
chess in which case uh
no Levy another chat question from po8
RG are you more worried about facing
Trent or shalva in the final and is
there someone that you'd rather face
from let's say a Content perspective not
a leading question at all I thought you
said uh shabalov and I was like what the
f shabalov is in the like is that I am
not a GM uh yeah he got demoted he got
demoted uh for those that don't know
Alexander shabalov is a legendary uh
American grandmas has played in many US
championships I thought they snuck him
into the field to make things
interesting um I don't have a preference
I mean I'm excited to play uh either
person uh I I I will have to say I'm
between those two I think one of them
will probably trash talk a little bit
more so and that's obviously Pina shalva
you know she's got a big mouth she's
always talking trash
um just for those that are uninclined to
humor that that that is not serious uh
but I look forward I don't think I've
played many many games against Lawrence
and I I don't think I've played Pina at
all so
uh I'm I'm excited to see like where the
openings go where the preparation goes
and uh hopefully my second time in the
final in this event which has only
happened four times uh can go
differently because then I will qualify
it's like getting your yellow belt in
Taekwondo you know you don't need to do
the white belt stuff anymore uh that
that that'll be a big moment for me I
might you know hang it on the wall
behind
me Greg your thoughts on who you want to
see Levy face in the
final I mean it does you know I was
going to talk a lot of trash if somehow
I won but I I I just kind of I mean e
either player
because well Paulina seems very
strong so probably she'll win but
Lawrence has like uh tricks I guess like
cheap tricks and tactics like that and
sometimes in bullet and Blitz they work
out but I don't I don't I think Pina
vers um Levy would be a really close
match the other one I'm not sure not so
much Greg it's always uh fun to hear
thoughts on any match
but where's third place that's what I'm
wondering well not this time but maybe
something to add in the future but we do
have one last featured chat question
it's for you Greg and it's from nuke
town and they want to know are you
subscribed to Gotham
chess um maybe subscribe which that's on
Twitch when you like pay the
money sorry no it's it's on YouTube I
have been before it's on YouTube it's
YouTube I'm definitely like following
subscribing and I I know I have been at
times am I right now I don't know I
haven't checked my subscriptions I don't
want to lie but
maybe but you know I love I love content
a follow
button let me just say something about
Levy and and what he's doing for chess
um I'm at like parties I go to part when
I'm at a party and people like they
don't know anything about Chess but they
like follow it a little bit and there's
always one person they know it's like yo
do you know Gotham chess and I'm like
yeah he beats me in bullet every
year that's funny
um well that is uh that is very sweet I
appreciate that very much Craig uh and
uh I look forward to our third match in
this event in every season of this event
in the
future uh that'll be so much fun we will
be permanent in the IM
leagues it was fun though good well you
both have provided a lot of fun and
entertainment to everybody so Greg sorry
that this is where your tournament ends
but Levy we look forward to seeing you
later this week in the final and
congrats again and yeah thanks for all
you're doing both of you
congrats thanks guys thank
you and there you have it there is one
face on the screen and it's none other
than Levy rosman's better known as
Gotham chess he takes on well it's
unclear who he will face it could be
Paulina shalva or Lawrence Trent that
was a really fun matchup between Levy
and Greg 1311 is your final score da any
final thoughts before we wrap the show
it was an amazing match and I've
commentated enough SEC matches across
the years just to have that six sense
going into a match you can feel it when
it's going to be close when it's going
to be entertaining this match delivered
on everything that we could ask of it
and then some it went down to the wire
it went into overtime ultimately Levy's
bullet skills his composure and his
performance Under Pressure he strikes
again and he will have a very difficult
Journey to the final but if he keeps
playing the way he is if he keeps
displaying the same level of composure
and power I think he's got every shot at
taking the whole
event or Levy it will be a difficult
journey in the final no matter who he
faces but he'll have a very pleasant
journey early next year so for those of
you who want to meet Gotham chess AKA
Levy Rosman AKA your imcc finalist you
will have an opportunity to do just that
so join us in Charlotte North Carolina
for the first ever chess kid national
festival book your tickets now for 4
days of Chess festivities including over
theboard tournaments and opportunity to
meet special guests like fun Master Mike
Chief chess officer Danny wrench Gotham
chess and Daniel nitzki yes you heard
that right da will be there I got a long
way to travel Robert I know about that
yes it's a far car ride February 16th to
19th we cannot wait to see you there so
use the command Festival in chat to
learn more and register today da he'll
be there I depends we'll see if da can
convince me but where we definitely will
be is back here tomorrow same time same
place the imcc it's chess.com event
featuring many of the world's greatest
content creators and very strong players
in their own right we congratulate Levy
Rosman tomorrow we will see Pina Shala
and Lawrence Trent you'll not want to
miss the action so stop by tomorrow see
you
then
[Music]
bye
Jack
[Music]
it what
what Jack it out what
[Music]
what
he
[Music]
I
sh
[Music]
by